You create without bullshit. Very important when you recreate,
you have no bullshit.
So it's Eric wines dying,
not Weinstein. Yeah. I think it was originally van stein.
Van Stein ? Dane. Oh, vine [inaudible] German. Yeah. But uh,
Shah, it was, uh, we,
we came from a town between a Dessa and key of called [inaudible].
And that's where the family, the, the vine stain family came from.
We talked about how many people mispronounce Weinstein instead of Weinstein.
It's, it's epidemic. And yet nobody ever says Albert Einstein.
Yes. That's w yeah. Strange. Right? That is a weird one.
The Einstein is, no, no. Is there a guy named Mike? I'm like, Oh,
Mike Einstein. No, no, no. I N steam. Is there a guy like that?
[inaudible] do you remember the old, a blazing Saddles with a chore? Mel Brooks,
Mel Brooks,
and a Harvey Korman character was Hedley Lamarr and everyone would call him
Hetty Lamar. That was like the running joke in the picture. That's right.
I fucking loved Mel Brooks movies.
Do you remember the Yiddish speaking Indians that had to be the best? Oh yeah,
that's right. He had some great movies. Man.
There's fun fucking movies, man. Just silly, fun,
outrageous movies. Yeah. I mean, he was, he was transitional, right?
I guess it was the Borscht belt being updated for the modern era. Yeah.
In the film. But it was also, it was,
you know, for the time, much more contemporary,
but with that sort of Borshbelt sort of Shticky sorta right in the writers'
room,
I guess from Sid Caesar's show of shows was this legendary factory before
Saturday night live for all of these kinds of crazy talents behind the scenes.
I think he came out of that with Carl Reiner. Ah, that makes sense. He's,
how old is Mel Brooks? Now?
I don't want to ask the question because maybe something will happen. I know,
right? It's one of the,
I think I saw recently that he turned 93 and I thought, shit,
is he dead like Melbourne? You know,
because they were saying all these great things. Mel Brooks, I'm like, fuck,
did we lose Mel Brooks? But it's like one of those things.
Where is it? It's going to happen. I mean,
he's 93 I know, but every time it does, I know. I mean,
I guess a WHO, Betty White is another one of these people. Right? Right.
And so we need these very exotic links to our past. Um,
and they become more important as time goes on if they're still vital because
you know, we want desperately to be connected to something before you know,
our current era.
Given that I think a lot of us sort of don't believe in anything that happened
before Google. Bright. Imagine kids today.
Imagine trying to describe to kids today what it was like to grow up without the
Internet.
Yeah. Or not being able to reach people.
You have to make extensive plans and you know, backup plans. Well,
if you're not there at this time. Yeah. I used to have to yell,
open up your window, yell for your friends.
I remember when I first got an answering machine,
I thought it was the most amazing thing ever. When I was in high school,
my family got an answering machine and I was like, this is incredible.
And you would, you would leave like stupid music.
Like to let everybody know you were cool. Like you have some cool music, like,
hey, it's Joe not here right now, but if you leave a message,
I'll get back to you probably.
And then you've got like old people who are, I think,
I think someone in my family still has one of these cutesy messages from like
the late eighties. Really? Yeah. On their voicemail, but then who,
who leaves voicemail and the thing that gets,
that marks me as an old person as I actually call people. But that's,
I like that. I've been doing that more lately. Yeah,
I call it a lot of people now. I just feel like it's just, it's better.
The t the texting thing.
The problem is if it's very interesting how we separated ourselves into this,
uh, the,
this electronic communication world where I will during the day be in
communication almost constantly with a stream of people.
The only thing that stops it is a podcast. Pos podcast is my,
my rest for three hours. I'm not talking to anybody other than you.
So all those texts that come through, I'll get the end of the podcast.
I'll go and look at my phone. There'll be 40 texts sometimes,
like this is madness. If I had to make 40 phone calls, there'd be no,
it would be impossible to manage. It would be a,
I'd be calls would constantly be coming in.
You'd never really be able to say anything. So we're,
we're feeding into this weird loop where we just have these short form things
like, Hey, dinner tomorrow. Sure. What time? How about nine? I can do seven.
Okay, let's do it. You know what I mean?
It's like these weird little bursts of information. You ever see a,
remember this program, California and what was it called? Uh,
was a Californication television show with the, yeah, with the X. Right.
So there's the scene where he's having some really hot intergenerational sex and
this gal says like lol, and it kills it, said it out loud. She said, she says,
lol and he loses total interest.
There's no amount of heat in the moment that can compensate for the fact that
she's using like verbal emojis. Hmm.
Well he needs to fucking get over that. How hot she is.
And it also depends on how you say it. If she's really funny and she's like,
lol, you know, and she's like being silly. Like I said, like, you know,
I learned that from, I learned that from Jim Norton.
Jim Norton will always say lol. Like he'll,
he'll say something really ridiculous and then say, lol,
but he's just mocking himself. You're over 50. It's intrinsically ironic.
But you know, in terms of this weird thing about islands of time,
one of the things that we do is have a Shabbat
dinner and every Friday, uh,
no matter how atheist and militant people are against any kind of organized
religion, they will leave us alone. Uh, when,
if we say we're going into Shabbat. Ah, and so there's this thing about, um,
like people will pester me and all sorts of situations,
but if I invoke something that is vaguely religious,
even Sam Harris probably wouldn't call me during that period of time.
I find that very interesting. Like, could you,
could you create a religion that was simply there to make sure that you had some
time offline? Yeah, I know if I texted bench Piero,
I'm not getting a text back on Saturday and it was dark. Yup.
But when it's dark he texts you.
But as soon as there are three stars in the sky, there's been on Twitter.
It's like, what did I miss? That's so weird. It's so,
it's so weird that people buy, I mean, on one hand,
I think it's probably a really good idea to just take a break from all that
electronic shit and just connect with humans in a,
in a very old school type of way.
I think it's probably very good for connect with yourself.
I had this experience,
I actually lived in Jerusalem for two years and we landed,
uh, in this orthodox run hotel and on Friday night everything shut down,
you know, like the textbook. And I then moved into a,
uh, uh, an ultra orthodox neighbor, uh, neighborhood, right in the,
on the boundary of, um, a place where the secular and the Orthodox meant.
What was really fascinating to me is I started telling people, you know,
you'd never think that, uh,
it's great not to be able to find a restaurant or a nightclub,
but it's amazing that if this is enforced downtime,
and about a month in somebody said, uh Oh, you're in the wrong place.
Of course you can go out on Friday night. You just go to the,
the Russian Compound and everything's hopping and you can go dancing and
drinking and all these things.
After I knew that I went dancing and drinking and I was much less happy than
believing that somehow Israel actually shut down on Friday nights.
And so very weirdly, I appreciated the constraint.
As soon as I knew you could break the constraint,
I was less happy and I would never actually obey it anymore. Yeah.
I think having a rigid rule, even though it seems con,
it seems like counterintuitive and that in that like it would provide you some
freedom by having restrictions. But it does, it gives you some freedom. Like,
okay, like now we don't have to think about all these other things.
So now we have the freedom to just be alone.
Now we have the freedom to be relaxed.
Now we have the freedom to just talk to human beings. You know,
I think constraints and it's like the do you know Jocko is Jocko Willink.
Totally. Everybody knows Jocko. Um, discipline equals freedom.
Discipline equals freedom. Doesn't seem like that. Makes Sense.
Like this is up at four 30 in the morning throwing heavyweights around grunting
and acting like a savage running goes out to the beach
and he earns a sunrise every morning. It goes out and takes photos. You know,
it takes a photo of his fucking watch at four 30 hits the gym like a savage and
then takes a photo sometimes with the sunrise earning the sunrise.
And you're like,
but you would think God is like a prison to like force yourself into that.
But no, no.
He knows there's freedom in that because he knows he doesn't have to make any
decisions at four 30. He knows what he's gonna do.
He knows what he's going to do. You just, you just go do it. And that way.
I mean, you look at the guy, he's a fucking tank. Why is he a tank?
Cause he's always up at four 30 fucking throwing weights around.
It just doesn't, he never stops. He never, never takes,
never takes self-indulgent time to lay in bed and beat off and pick his nose and
fucking check his text messages. Listening
to this right now and thinking maybe I do a little bit of that.
I don't think he does really. Total discipline. Yeah. Well, did you,
I think I remember reading, um,
his inner dialogue about going to a birthday party and breaking down and having
a scoop of ice cream or something or slice the pie and it's like, you know,
the drama of there. It was temptation.
I held out for 45 minutes, but eventually I became weak. Yeah.
I don't fuck with that. I just do it. I'm going to parties. He backache,
you know, I mean I just feel like I do enough. I'm all right. We'll be fine.
There's this story about Jackie o that she got this cancer diagnosis and
apparently her first words upon finding out that she had metastatic cancer was
then what did I do all those setups for? I'm going to interesting comment.
That's an interesting comment. She thought somebody needed to talk to her.
John JFK was keeping her in the dark. Is that right? Yeah,
it must be what's happening over there, Jamie? Something about DV. Um, yeah,
like telling her that setups that you want. You want no cancer setups ups.
That's the way to do it, I guess. I don't know. I mean, I think, I think we all,
we have so many days of our lives that we build this pattern that this is going
to go on forever. And there is some first moment,
I think I recall it where the phrase popped into my head.
I can see my death from here and it has to do, you know,
there's like this weird thing when you hit 40,
you start to be able to have analytic thoughts that are uninterrupted by sex
rowing. Yeah. I Dunno. When I, when I turned 40, I found that, um,
some aspect of, uh,
thinking too much about sexuality definitely decreased.
And then you start to realize like you're,
when your testosterone starts to go down, you don't feel your,
you don't feel like yourself. Yeah. You become a different thing. Yeah.
When your chemical composition changes the way your body feels changes,
the way you interface with the world changes. Like I wasn't,
I wasn't feeling all that great yesterday and I was sort of clowning around with
the person behind the bar at Starbucks and she said, oh, why are you down?
I said, I don't know, just tell me something nice about my hair, you know,
she says
it wasn't me. She says, oh, it's, I love salt and pepper. I thought,
Dang. Oh really? Worst is that you're barely salt and pepper.
I can barely see any salt. She's talking about the song. She's both bullshit.
And you know, she just didn't want me flirting with her,
so she just shut me down by saying, you want me to talk about your hair? Okay.
You crossed the threshold here. Yeah. That's all right. Yeah.
As soon as someone says, say something nice like that could get ugly for a girl.
Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. And she was in a captive situation,
wasn't being fair to her. Oh yeah, right.
Does that is the worst when someone's stuck behind a bar,
established a rapport before that? Actually,
I actually think she thought it was a kind insensitive comment,
but I don't see any salt. I'm looking now, I'm just fishing John.
Their sounds might be a few,
but not like somebody's going to screenshot it and they going to count all the
hairs with arrows.
This is something I've learned when you come on your show that your audience is
so large and active that they will,
they will pinpoint every like timestamp. Yeah.
There's a lot of people in cubicles right now wasting their employer's time to
those people. We solutions you. Cheers.
I should say for the folks at home that before we started this,
you asked me did I want Laird Hamilton coffee and I said Laird Hamilton coffee
with [inaudible] coffee and you gave me something laced with turmeric,
which may turn our lips funny colors. So if it doesn't not drink it every day.
All right, that's fine. All right. It's really good though.
But it does give you a little phlegm, a little [inaudible],
a little bit of that cause it's got all sorts of MCT oil and all sorts of great
stuff in there. Layered Hamilton's a real freak. Really interesting.
What a pioneer. Yeah,
just like just talking to them and hanging out with them and seeing how his
brain works. Like you got to do that. Yeah. I'm on a podcast. Yeah,
it was really, really fun. So did you, what is he, okay.
This is something I'm totally curious about.
I don't Surf because surfing is, in my estimation,
going through some kind of a renaissance right now.
I'm super keen to understand what the series of innovations are given that lots
of other things aren't innovating at anything. Like the surfing innovation rate.
Well the big one is that new type of surfboard. What the hell is that call?
It's like a soil foil. Yeah. Foil. That thing is amazing and it doesn't,
it's, it's so weird looking. If you look at it, you're like,
why are you standing on? Like why is it elevated?
What's the magic carpet of the sea? Let's be honest. That's what it is.
And I am obsessed. I was asking you before, um,
there's this Guy Kyle Lennie who for me is just redefining surfing by taking
these monster waves and he's turning them into his private little skate park and
doing tricks off the top of skyscraper waves. And I'm just thinking,
do you even know what you're doing or where you are?
And he's saying he keeps saying this one phrase,
which is I'm just scratching what blows my mind is I'm just scratching the
surface.
He knows that he's making that discontinue to newest jump.
And if you,
if you think about sport from the perspective of when did things just change?
Like almost overnight.
You know Bob Beamon are arguably is one of the great moments in all of sporting
history and it happens in the long junk just because you have an incremental
sport that suddenly, you know,
somebody jumps a foot more than anyone's ever jumped before,
something like that. So it's really interesting when somebody changes the game.
It is.
And when you find out that there's stuff that you can do and other sports like
skate sports, like different crazy flips and stuff,
when someone figures out how to do that on a wave,
the consequences are so fucking grave. If you make a mistake in,
you're on an 80 foot wave and that bitch comes slamming down on you.
But part of the innovation is safety, right? Like with these vests,
inflatable vests and with these water,
water safety courses for big wave surfers. Um,
I think that what's fascinating is you think the innovation is in the tricks
maybe, but maybe the innovation is actually in, hey,
you can afford a two way of hold down in a way you couldn't before or you're
going to survive all sorts of things that might've been fatal. Right, right.
So you have this open area to innovate. Yeah,
that makes, I mean, surfing's fascinating to me. I don't do it.
I haven't done it,
but I went snorkeling when I was in Hawaii last a couple of weeks ago and I'm
such a pussy. I'm just, uh, I'm, I'm smoking with my kids. Right.
So of course like I'm trying to figure out how to be the,
the mama duck and like corral everybody's off the sharks common. It gets me,
I'm just trying to, I'm just looking around cause some guy got gas,
he got jacked. Um,
I think snorkeling in Maui just a couple months ago. Oh,
like right off of a resort. Tiger shirt. Probably. Yeah, probably. Yeah.
Yeah. Well so yeah, some lady got it yesterday, not yesterday,
a couple days ago in, was it The Bahamas? Three sharks.
One took her arm off and the other two just ripped her apart in front of
everybody. Ollege kid from, from California. Well,
I'm very interested in situations that change with sharks.
Like reunion for example,
in the Indian Ocean off of Madagascar used to be a surfing hot spot and they had
a bull shark problem where the bull sharks just sort of learned how to eat.
Humans are attack humans.
But the great thing is we have got some weird thing going on with the True Apex
Predator of the seas, which is the Orca.
We have one recorded bite in the wild ever.
Now how does this make any sense?
Like great whites are not apex predators because orchids will just take them
out. And I had this poll on Twitter the other day,
which is uh, Orca has colon, um,
best species ever was number one.
Then the other possibility was the dicks of the deep because there's such
asshole. I didn't know that there was a recorded bite of anyone in the wild.
I thought it was all in captivity. No, there's a certain,
there was a surfer who got a bite. Really? Yeah. But you know,
on the other hand, how are you going to make contact if you're an Orca?
You don't have opposable thumbs. It might be for all I know.
I mean look what has to be a joke. Cause otherwise the guy would be dead.
I mean if Oracle wanted to kill you and you're in the water,
that's like if you let a an ant go, okay,
but why have orchids never attacked us?
There's so many recorded instances of swimmers, paddle boarders,
surfers or ending into orchids. Some weird thing is going on.
And we have to, we have to work this out, Joe. Yeah, let's try,
because we've got, well, first of all,
what assholes or way that we have those goddamn things in captivity and a big
fucking shout out to Canada because Canada mostly probably through the noise
that my friend Phil Demars has created in trying to get marine land shut down.
Canada is banned all Orca and all dolphin captivity. It's amazing.
And I hope the United States does it as well. I hope it,
I hope it goes worldwide. It's, I think it's,
I think it's slavery. I really do. I think it's a different kind of slavery.
They're almost us. They're like a cross between us and wolves in,
in the [inaudible]. Well, they have,
they just don't have the ability to manipulate their environment,
but they have a cerebral cortex. A dolphin does.
It's 40% larger than the human beings. That's what is going on there.
Like the cerebral cortex. So there's thinking happening there,
like really complex, high, really thinking, well,
am I right that they have menopause? Like they're the only,
essentially the only other species with menopause.
And you're only gonna get menopause likely if females are contributing,
uh, some sort of intellectual labor past their reproductive, uh,
horizon. How was that? Because well,
I thought menopause was just a shift in the hormonal balance of well,
what is the purpose, uh,
evolutionarily of continuing life beyond,
um, the ability to reproduce? That's a good point because that's doesn't,
that's not the case in mammals and mammals dear in particular,
can breed deep into their old, old age.
If you have a resource that's limiting you,
you'd be better off in terms of systems of selective pressures of shifting
something that is continuing past that point. You know,
this is the old point of it. I think it was Henry Ford who used to go to the,
uh, the dump to see what broke down on the cars and what was still working.
And they would transfer materials and resources from things that were dependably
found to work to the things that would be the limiting feature that would break
so that the cars would all break down sort of uniformly at the end.
And you see this like with salmon or salmon disintegrate because it's a discrete
heist, a democratized reproductive strategies.
No Salmon's going to make another run.
So you might as well go out in a blaze of glory. Right? Yeah.
That's interesting. Um,
they also have a massive infanticide, you know,
that's the horrible thing about dolphins. They're, they're ruthless.
They killed her babies. The male dolphins will kill female dolphins,
babies in order to force them into estrus. Yeah.
And that the strategy that the female dolphins have, uh, acquired to, uh,
mitigate that is that they become slots because the male dolphins don't know
whether or not the females baby is theirs because they don't have 23 in me under
the ocean.
So what happens is the female will have sex with as many males as she can.
So that way she's protected and her child's protected because then all the males
think it could possibly be their baby. They don't want to kill their own baby,
which is really interesting that they differentiate because many mammals that
also participate in this don't like bears, don't differentiate between their,
their babies and someone else's babies. So the females in, you know,
if she's carrying around cubs, the male will try to kill and eat the cubs.
So to force her back and asterisks and perhaps just even for food because
they're so ruthless and cannibalistic.
But dolphins who we think of as our beautiful, charming,
wonderful little buddies in the water, they kill babies.
They killer whales are of course dolphins. Yes, there are type of Dolphin. So,
you know, the, the issue is, you know, I think about why,
why do we not get attacked? It's like professional courtesy.
Assholes recognize that. I don't know man.
But every time I go to Hawaii, uh, we, we swim with,
we either not swim with dolphins, but we're in,
if you're in a boat and you go fishing,
the dolphins find the boat and they swim with the boat. I've never done that.
Oh Dude, it's here. I'll show you a little video.
It's kind of wild because what they do is they literally go and they hang out
with the wave of your boat. So as your boat is a,
as your boat is tuning along, they, they, they ride the wake.
They figure out a way how to do that.
They figured out a way to get in front of the boat and as the boat is pushing
the water, they just sort of like helps them along.
Almost like reverse drafting cause they're kind of in front of it.
So as you're pushing the water, let me find it here. It's really interesting,
man. They're there. An incredible little animal. I mean it's so here it goes.
So that's us in the boat. That's way cool. Yeah,
no wild. Just wild. They just hang out with you.
I mean wild fucking dolphins, middle of the ocean. They don't know you.
You can be an asshole.
They trust you enough to the trying to get our technology. Joe.
They want the boats. I don't think so. You don't think so?
You think we're trapped by that shit. They're laughing herring around all this.
We can do this, can you? Yeah. They don't have to carry anything.
We were carrying everything by ourselves. We're almost useless. Naked. Useless.
We have to have clothes. You have to carry the clothes. You have to have shoes.
You got to have a rule. Man, we're extended phenotype guys. Yes. Yeah.
They think we're fools. They think we're full. Yeah.
They're out there with free food.
They don't have to worry about carrying credit cards, bitcoin,
all that nonsense. They're out there in the ocean.
I bet they have bitcoin and things pointed the deep pash. I don't think they do.
Um,
I think they're probably pretty pissed that we've killed all the fish though.
Yeah. I think that they're actually a little, you know, the,
the org has figured out how to use our fishers or fishing boats and just wait
for us to get stuff on the line and then they like a steal.
Thank you for organizing my dinner. Ha.
Well some orchids are not that smart because they're not adapting.
Like there's a particular pod in the Pacific northwest that relies on Chinook
Salmon. Oh yeah.
And they're trying to figure out a way cause the salmon populations massively
depleted due to a bunch of different factors,
including they put dams up and they've done a bunch of stupid shit that they
didn't,
they did a long time ago and they didn't really understand the consequences of
it. And it's really been devastating to the salmon population up there.
And Chinook Salmon in particular because this is what these orchids eat.
Now,
they also have this migratory pod that comes in that relies on marine mammals,
and the migratory pod is doing great, brilliant. They're doing great.
They're eating all the seals and they're having a good old time.
But for whatever reason,
the pod that stays in that area doesn't want to eat marine mammals.
They only want to eat Chinook salmon.
So they're fucking literally starving to death.
And I think they read this book on fixed versus growth mindset.
And the transitory transient pods are like, Hey, every day is a new day,
we could do something different. The other ones have no,
I'm kind of a creature of habit. You know, they're eating the salmon,
they're coming back.
They just have a very specific diet that they just won't deviate from,
which I find, I find to be really weird. What is it that pods missing right now?
Cause they probably all dead. They haven't,
they haven't been seen in over three weeks,
which is the longest they have been gone for. Oh, Washington's resonant.
Orchids go missing. Oh yeah. I remember that. Like,
no new babies had been born in the Puget sound. I hope. Um,
I hope they're not dead. And that's horrible. I don't know.
I sad because they can't figure out a way how to teach them to eat marine
animals. There's all these different strategies.
They've tried to figure out a way to teach them to eat seals,
but they're not interested. And they've also, um,
decided to try to figure out a way to farm raised Chinook Salmon and reintroduce
them to that area. But then again, you know, you don't have to, like,
how do you get,
how do you designate those salmons specifically for the orchids and not for
fishermen. Heck, what do you do when people, you know, they catch fish.
What do you do? Do you tell them, put it back? It's for the Orca. Hmm.
Yeah. Joanne, I don't have any actual expertise in this area. I mean,
either I'm just talking him. Well, you know,
we went down to a Hearst castle and there's this elephant seal colony there.
And my family decided that this is the worst species ever of mammal elephant
seals. Oh Man.
They're horrible. Like first of all, in terms of sexual dynamics, you know,
one beach master,
he's got a couple lieutenants who are trying to take over his role and the
lieutenants seemingly can have sex with one or two of the females,
like not too much, but just enough to keep them happy. Yeah, yeah. Right.
And then the beach masters have to fight each other and there are all these dead
babies all over the beach because the giant bowls,
uh, just trample them on their way to fights. Oh, right.
And so then, then you have like the females, if they lose the pup,
they've got to get rid of their milk. So they still somebody else's baby.
So the whole thing, if you transpose like human, if you anthropomorphize,
you just think these people are horrible.
This is a crack house on the beach and there's no way,
how do we get some great whites and then remove these mammals immediately?
They're making the family look bad. Yeah.
Maybe we could get the orchestra to eating. That's right. Yeah,
because orchestra, we have a deal. Yeah, and it's a big animal,
so it's a good meal. Look at those dead babies that is so fucked up. All dead.
But it might be, and they are lazy. They are not an industrious,
I mean they are when they're in the sea,
but when they're just on land or they're just laying there. Oh,
they're not dead. They're just chilling. Why they're showing, oh, come on.
You have them. There are a lot of them.
Well you've seen when work is due beach themselves to get those things right.
It's, yeah, it's, well th th th th it's right on the edge.
They hydro the hydroplane on the and then they waddle back in. Look,
I was like scratched up. They are from the ground and everything.
It's a weird looking animal too. What a weird fucking thing that is.
William Randolph Hearst was a real piece of shit. He really was. You know,
he's the reason why we have wild pigs in California.
That dip shit imported wild boars and released him on his property.
Okay. So we're driving down the highway and my son says, look dad,
wild zebras. I said, ha ha son. That's very cute. He says, no, no, no. Really?
I look up and there's a herd of wild zebras.
What her's castle has, they closed down the zoo.
They let the zebras out.
We have a herd of wild zebras in California that no one told me about.
Shut the fuck up. I serious. I've won the Joe Rogan experience.
I finally told you something you don't know anything about,
especially about invasive wildlife. That's crazy. So Zebra is in California.
That change your mind a little bit on Mr Hearse? No, he's a piece of shit.
Alright. He will that he's,
he's one of the main reasons why marijuana became illegal.
Was He smoking too much? Well,
it's all conspiracy theory and conjecture,
but the story is the traditional told by stoners with some education story is
that William Randolph Hearst,
along with Harry Anslinger conspired to make marijuana illegal.
When dupont came up with the chemical composition for nylon and
when it was a combination of several factors and the decorticator was invent
decorticator was a way that they could effectively process hemp fiber without
the use of slavery.
See the reason why they switched over from hemp clothing and hemp sales and
canvas canvas, which is actually comes from the word cannabis.
All cannabis was made from hemp. Yes. All that stuff is made from hap.
It's far superior to a cotton far superior in terms of a strength in terms of
the durability that was in June. I don't know what Jude is. Judas, what?
Burlap bag like, oh, shoot is way better than that stuff. Okay. No,
hemp is up alien plant. It's hemp. If you had a piece of hemp,
like the stock of Hamp and you cut it into boards like this table that it would
be as hard as this oak, but as light as Balsa wood,
it's incredibly strange. I, um,
I've seen these like the actual stock of a hemp tree when it gets really big and
you'll have it thick around like, like a man's shoulder. Right.
But it weighs like nothing. It's really strange. It's a strange, strange plant.
Not like any other plant. It has all the essential amino acids.
It contains protein. You can cook with the oil,
the oil can sustain you. It's got essential fatty acids.
When do we have to ban it? Oh, it's fucking amazing. Amazing plant. But anyway,
um, they came out with his decorticator and the decorticator because the,
the way they used to do it,
it was like a very labor intensive process of breaking down the hemp fiber and
turning it into something that you can make clothes within paper.
So Popular Science magazine in, see if you could find the cover of this.
And like the 19, early 1930s, it had a cover set hemp,
the new billion dollar crop. Uh,
and because they had this decorticator right.
So we ran off Hearst on top of having Hearst publications.
Right. He also had paper mills because you know, he had a,
he wanted to make his own paper.
So we had these forests and he had paper and he,
he would make paper out of wood. There is, well,
does it say there's a cover of it though that says hemp hemp,
the new billion dollar crop. That's just the inside part of it.
See if you can find it. Anyway, um,
so William Randolph Hearst would've had to have shift over because hemp paper
and revere played with it. Nope, it's incredibly durable. It's crazy.
It's a guitar to tear. It's really fucking strong.
Like it's a fucking alien plant. There's nothing like it. It's so weird.
Like you see a piece of paper, you think,
oh look at this light piece of paper to tear it. No, no, no.
Fucking really durable.
So they were saying this was going to replace all paper that's made out of wood
and William Randolph Hearst was like slowly roll bitches. I got an idea.
So he starts putting together all these stories about Mexicans and blacks that
are smoking this drug called marijuana
and they're raping white women.
And when Congress made marijuana illegal,
they probably didn't even understand that it was hemp because it was the same
goddamn thing. Marijuana was a Mexican slang for tobacco for a while,
tobacco. So they repurposed this name and called it this,
this plant called this marijuana,
like it was this gigantic conspiracy so that this fucking piece of shit can save
money. All right? That's really what it was. Cause he had access.
He was like the youtube and the Google of you know,
you belonged with third man. He did believe he had access.
He was the one who could decide what gets distributed and so he that's,
and that was big part of the whole reefer madness film campaign and all that
Shit. All of that stuff was all about economics.
The whole thing was about economics.
American farmers are promised a new cash crop with an annual value of several
hundred million dollars. All because of a machine has been invented,
which solves problems in more than 6,000 years old. It is hemp,
a crop that will not compete with other American products. Instead,
it will displace imports of raw material and manufactured products produced by
underpaid peasant and Cooley Labor. Cooley labor. Wow. What does that mean?
I don't even know what that means. Let's not talk about it. One means, nope.
Nope.
It will provide thousands of jobs for American workers throughout the land.
So this was all in February, 1938.
They thought they were gonna they were gonna change the world with this shit.
And then you had all these people that were a part of the whole prohibition for
alcohol. They just shifted those motherfuckers over to him. I mean,
think about it, it's like over the period of, you know, 10, 15 years,
if you had 10 15 years ago, you know, we're talking about like, um, 2004,
you know,
you had bunch of people from the Bush administration that were really into
banning certain drugs and you still have them hanging around. You know,
I'll allow that. That dip shit,
that was the attorney general for awhile with the flux, his name,
that little weasel, that little weasel that Trump got rid of sessions,
that piece of shit, that guy. Same thing. Same thing.
These little weasel for good people don't smoke marijuana. But then little,
you know, he's a viper. He's a viper.
Is that what they used to call people who smoked weed back in the [inaudible]?
He's not smoking weed. He fucked up that. Look,
anytime I see somebody who's really against homosexuality, I set a clock.
Yeah. Right. Yeah.
And you have to ask yourself who in the modern era.
Like I found it astounding that when Ilan came on this program and had a blood
that like it was an issue. Yeah.
And can you imagine if like Elan it had a glass of Chardonnay?
Well he did. Yeah, I know. But the,
just the fact that our language and our thought process around this every right,
I see what you're saying. I had a dinner, um,
at our house a while ago where we took some of the most, uh,
knowledgeable on psychedelics and related substances to just have a discussion
about what is the state of schedule one pharmacology.
And we asked a question of the, um,
interesting substances.
What are the three that you find were most informative in terms of self
revelation, uh, changing your understanding for the better, et cetera.
I was astounded that of the people who seemed to be very knowledgeable about,
uh, mind altering substances, almost everyone put, uh,
cannabis in the top three. My, because it so well I,
I thought it'd be sort of commonplace, you know, I wouldn't have guessed,
you know, somebody would say five Meo DMT. Somebody else would say ketamine.
Somebody else would say, um, you know,
LSD or DMT or I WASFA. Um,
but the common thread throughout all of these people who were many of them were
researchers, um,
was that they felt that cannabis was miraculous substance. Well, it certainly,
well the deal is it has two different forms, right? As a smokable form,
which you know, you can get really fucking high or it has the edible form,
which is like a psychedelic, but it's like a psychedelic,
very much so. It actually is more psychoactive. There's,
there's something called 11 hydroxy metabolite, that old,
it's only precedent when you eat it. I say it's processed by the liver.
There's something called a onepass and when it goes through the liver produces
this 11 hydroxy metabolite that's somewhere between four and five times more
psychoactive than THC.
And it's responsible for people thinking that they got dosed.
Like a lot of times when people eat edibles to go like, oh my God,
this is in pot, something's in there. Well it's just the 11 hydroxy metabolites.
That's what it is. It's nomadic. Yeah, it's way different. It's way different.
Like that's why it's confusing to people like, oh I can't fuck with edibles.
It's a different drug.
It's a different drug because 11 hydroxy metabolite is not present in
psychoactive form when you smoke it. So when you eat it,
that's when you get that really fucking weird body high and interdimensional
relationship. Is it better, worse? It's more interesting.
Well for the tank it's Bueno.
It's the best for the isolation tank. That's my favorite.
My favorite is a good stiff dose of an edible of an edible and then you know,
wait about 45 minutes and then get in the tank so cause 45 minutes.
It's like the way I describe it as like with certain psychedelic drugs and I do
consider edible marijuana psychedelic,
especially when you get into the hundred milligram,
200 milligram doses.
It's very psychedelic and especially in the tank because in the tank when in the
absence of any visual stimulation you're, when your eyes are closed,
you have these wild, almost like neon visuals like I start,
you start seeing these strange dancing cartoons and like weird,
weird shit unrelated
to other substances.
You can get similar situations on other psychedelics,
especially in the tank that the tank is a really unique way to experience
anything. Even even normal psych,
like the normal state,
the normal state of consciousness that you have without any drugs at all inside
the tank, it transforms, right?
Because in the absence of any sensory input and you don't have anything coming
your way, you don't feel your scan,
your brain starts really getting free and loose and you start,
you, it gets very confusing as to what's reality and what's not.
What are the boundaries of, of,
of vision and interpretation and just creativity. Like what,
how much of this is your imagination? How much of this is not what you,
when you add any sort of psychedelic to that tank experience,
everything gets ramped up. It's like, you know, it's like, you know,
you add some drugs when you mix them with other drugs,
they become like way more potent that what happens in the tank.
The tank in and of itself is some kind of a drug or it produces some kind of
profound drug like effects. Like can it be banned? The tank,
I don't think you can have you, how much experience you have with the tank. Uh,
not much. How many times have you done it?
I've been in once and it was when I was a teenager comment, you should have one.
You really should. It's just a great way to relax too. It's a great way.
And you as a mathematician, you think of things and your con you,
you're spending a lot of time contemplating things and you have to realize that
any other input,
whether we think about it or not is chewing up some bandwidth.
Although I actually
heavy kind of ambient level of distraction,
which is how most helpful for look when I get out there I get way the hell out
there and see like an ambient level of distraction sometimes. For example,
I'll go to an all night cafe at like two in the morning and there'll be just
enough human, I mean, I have very ambiguous feelings about humans.
Don't worry, I don't consider you one. What are you,
what do you consider yourself? We'll talk about this one. Oh No,
I really think that in many ways I've left this planet. Really? Yeah.
I think that there's a way in which I've checked out how so. Well, um,
I think that, um,
when you get deep enough into your own mind and you start dealing with
abstractions and you find that the real world, I wasn't planning on going here,
but we can try. Um, when you find that the real world, uh,
is often a kind of noisy, um,
place to think and that you actually prefer really powerful abstractions and
then you check in with the real world to say,
does that abstraction actually govern the world that I'm in?
You start to prefer, um, living in the abstractions.
That's interesting. Like,
do you feel the same way about like a crowded nightclub?
Like if you go to a bar and do you, do you find that that stimulates thinking?
Well, it depends. I mean, if I'm in a stimulating conversation,
I'm very present. Hmm. If I'm in an unstimulating conversation,
I have to make my own fun. Right.
And so I will start to sort of play, I mean, you know,
at times I'll just make up a story and see how it flies. Um, you know,
if I don't think I'm hurting anybody and sometimes I'll sort of experiment with
people, I think we'll all do it. You experiment with people.
Well sure. Like you like say something to someone to see if they bite. Well,
you know, it's like, let's, let's imagine for example,
you were going to move to Austin. Okay.
Are you going to just be the same old you?
You're not going to take the opportunity to perhaps reinvent yourself.
So for example, um, you know,
if I suddenly change,
if I start wearing glasses and I wear like a really fashion forward pair of
spectacles, you should wear aviators with yellow lenses like hunter s Thompson.
I would like that. I like that with you. With your crazy hair,
you would some yellow aviators and don't even address it, Tony. I'm in public.
Yeah, I'm indoors. But if I do any sort of alteration, like maybe,
maybe I've never seen my, what I look like with a bald head.
So if I were to Mitch, if I was going to move cities,
when's the best time to try it? Try something new. Right. And so you know,
at our, at our age, Joe, yes. Um, how old are you? 53.
Yup. That's all right. Yeah, I'm 51, almost 52.
So w the great danger is complacency. And so I, I,
I'm terrified about becoming complacent. So I always want to experiment chain.
Like what is it that I could continue to do to grow?
And if you can't play and experiment, like maybe,
you know, imagine you wanted to,
you wanted to go by Joseph and just to see whether it worked, you know,
whatever it is, we get so locked in and if we change anything,
people get angry.
And I've always looked at Madonna and David Bowie as like genius squared.
Not only did each iteration of them do something that was kind of artistically
interesting, but they habituated their audience for change.
And so the idea is that every time you, you met a different David Bowie,
you know, he would effectively say,
do you like this incarnation of me because it's not going to be,
it's only here for one year and then I'm going to do something new.
The next time there just had, um, conversation with Sean Linen,
um, in which we talked about how his father, John Lennon, uh,
always kept changing.
And yet people want to plug in with the idea that John Lennon was just the guy
who wrote, imagine let's say. Right. And that's,
that's a great dangerous that if you think about like your, somebody will say,
well, you know, it didn't you in 2014 tweet
X. Gotcha. It's like, well, yeah,
maybe you have 10,000 tweets and maybe you changed. Maybe,
maybe new information came in. So yeah,
that is a weird thing about pulling up thoughts that you had from a decade or
more ago and trying to put them on you today.
Yeah. And pretend. And if you say, I don't think that way anymore,
people don't want to accept that they will because it's a disingenuous
conversation.
They're not really trying to find out what you think they're trying to get you.
It's more interesting. For example, um,
there's been a ton of pressure. We can get to this in a second too.
For me to address the question of the IDW, is it still alive? Is it in trouble?
National Dark Web. Yeah. So it is the intentional,
the dirt dirt bag with the, um, let's come back to that.
When Cher did this, a remake of,
I got you babe with Beavis and butthead. You took this, remember,
cause she had this duet with Sonny Bono and then she got into a bad thing with
sunny and so she said,
I'm going to rerecord the song and I'm just going to torch it right now.
The problem is somebody had that as their wedding song, right?
Beavis and butthead. No, no, no. Was sowing. Yeah. Oh, let me see.
We probably did it with Beavis and butthead, but there's some punk.
They don't care. People from Florida. That one right. That's Florida man. He's,
um,
the problem when you change things is that other people wed themselves to where
you were. So when you pull up and you say, yeah,
I don't think that that's just wrong. I was confused man.
I was going through a dark time and I probably was saying stuff I should,
if you do that right,
anybody who sort of invested in that version of you and integrated that into
their lives is now angry. They're upset. Wait a minute.
You pulled the rug out from under me. And so you know,
in part with what Bowie and Madonna did is they said, look,
these are stages and if you like that stage, that stage is yours.
But I'm not staying there.
And I think that that's sort of the more responsible way of doing it is that
you're allowed your evolution, but you have to let people know, um,
I'm going to do something totally different from time to time.
Or I like the idea of doing things that are just do it, just do it. Yeah.
Don't try to explain yourself constantly.
They didn't explain themselves like they just,
they did it in a clear enough way that people could understand the pattern.
And so you know, for example,
and this is something that I think would be kind of interesting to talk about,
um,
everybody is losing their mind at the moment in the space that you and I sort of
Co and habit of ideas and trying to figure out how do we remain sane and plugged
in and open hearted and open to new things but also rigorous and fair,
like all of these weird pressures, the ideas behind intellectual dark web
that you coined this,
this concept of having a bunch of people that have different ideologies but yet
share this common theme of wanting to have real honest communication and honest
conversations and try to figure out,
instead of looking at things from an ideological perspective,
look at things from an honest objective point and try to see the way other
people view things but hearted and not,
not trying to destroy each other and effectively trying to become the adults in
the room as we watched the kids run riot. Right? And, and, and not always,
not always achieving that now because I refuse to actually say what it was or
who was in it because there was a lot of pressure to codify it.
And I knew that if I codified it, uh, it would die. I want a membership card.
You have, you have one. But if I don't, if I don't get one, you have what?
There's a clubhouse. We just don't tell the members where it is because it's,
there's an article about the IDW that doesn't mention me. I'm like, yes,
yanking away. Yeah, I'm slipping away, but I like Pachino in three.
He's going to drag you back. There are,
there's been some discussion about certain members and certain people that are
losing their fucking marbles. Yeah. I think it's pressure, you know,
and I think, um, one of the things that we're all recognizing from,
whether it's the internet and the, or just celebrity in general,
which I think part of the culprit is,
especially if you're reading comments and articles that are written about you,
which I do not recommend if you are doing that and doing that. Don't do that.
If you're doing that, you are subject to a massive amount of pressure. Yeah,
it's a lot of pressure and sometimes people they apply that well.
Sometimes that pressure can help you.
Like if it's a good friend or a someone who you trust and it's done with
intellectual honesty and they just really,
they think that there's a maybe a flaw in your thinking or maybe this could help
you or maybe this is an issue and then you realize that and you self correct.
That's great.
But there's a lot of people that are bending to the will of the masses and they
also are responding to the pressure of the mass.
I don't even think it's the massive [inaudible] reasons I read my comments is
because I want to know what Russia's thinking that I'm not kidding.
Listen to me, Joe. Here we go. Let's go down the rabbit hole together for sure.
And we went and we talked about this recently,
let me just say this before you get going. Yeah,
we knew that something was going on years ago.
I used to have a message board and a on my message board or my website.
Um, it became problematic for legal reasons.
People were putting a bunch of illegal shit up there and I was kind of
responsible for them. A few issues came up where I was like, oh Jesus,
I'm going to, I'm going to get in real trouble.
We had an influx and by an influx I mean thousands and thousands of Russian
emails signing up for my message board.
I mean thousands with really similar email addresses and they would post and
pretend they're from fucking Cleveland or post and be mad
that we don't have enough Nazis on or whatever, whatever the fuck it would be,
you know? Right. It would just be just same thing that the IRA was doing,
the Internet research agency was doing with Facebook and Google and Twitter.
We were seeing this like four or five years ago that this stuff was kind of
happening where they were recognizing that the disease,
large portals of discussion. And so they,
they're trying to manipulate that discussion and turn certain discussions toxic
and certain and you know,
and come up with preposterous conspiracy theories and attack people for
nonsensical reasons.
Well this is the thing,
I keep seeing the same message modified a hundred different ways from a bunch of
accounts that have suspicious similarity.
Not One of these accounts usually is followed by anyone I care about.
And then they have a few high value accounts with blurry photographs.
Have a person that like I,
I think somebody like putting real money into that account to create a fake
person who just dog doggedly follows you and is constantly trying to talk to you
in your ear that account.
But how do you know that that's what that is and how do you know it's not just
some person that schizophrenia that really is really interested in Eric
Weinstock?
Couple Times I've tried to like talk to the person, ah,
and suddenly the thing vanishes. It's like, you're so disgusting.
I would never talk to you. It's like goodbye click. It's like, oh,
maybe they just panicked. It could be just a person. Well, that's the thing we,
we, you never know. On the other hand, um,
you remember when we took that photograph at that dinner, um,
there was this huge number of jokes about Ben Shapiro in a booster seat that
were all slightly different versions of the joke and all of the accounts.
We were like strikingly similar. [inaudible] I was thinking like, well, I,
I could imagine a little bit of this, but it's way too many,
and this is part of what I believe.
I believe that we are in a new world in which a lot of the grassroots stuff is,
is astroturf. And if you start to listen to it,
you start to get pushed. And I start to watch certain tactics.
I make models of the tactics. You know, like one of the tactics is, Gosh, Eric,
I once thought that you had a lot of integrity and now I know that x, you know,
if you don't, if you don't address this situation, I'm done following you.
It's like, oh, really, goodbye click. But,
uh, I believe that, um,
I believe that there are sophisticated players who are engaged in trying to
either boost our signal or start to alter the signal.
Somebody will be up, somebody will be down. Uh,
and then there's like really weird dynamics. Um,
I think that there's a very strange thing going on, not with Dave Ruben,
but with the crowd of people that is just trying to eat Dave Ruben and blind him
and confuse him. And this, uh,
you know, this, this Guy Sam Cedar, who do you think he's a Russian?
I hope he is. Well, I don't know. I don't think he's Russian,
but I do think that his, his, I think he has a grassroots following.
I don't think this is inauthentic that just loves to,
um, dark harass, well dunk drag. I hate this language.
I just kept thinking I liked the word Dunkin. Oh really? Yeah. It's fun. No,
I'm not. I'm not a fan. No, no, no, because it's just a cheapens all converse.
Oh, you got dunked on, you got dragged. It's just like,
oh this is that thing in third grade that I never figured out.
Well they found out that he won't engage with them and so they think it's cute
to just constantly shit on them.
And they also think it's cute to take anything that he says and interpret it in
the worst possible way possible and not think of it as him just being a guy
who's trying to talk about things on the fly and maybe isn't even prepared about
the subject at hand. Like one of the things that comes up on this show,
like you know,
we were talking before we were going to go on there where we're going to talk
about, I'm like, come on, let's just talk. Yeah. And so when you do that,
come on, let's just talk thing.
You never know what the fuck is going to come up.
And you might have a piss poorly formed idea of what a subject is and you just
start rambling. This is what I've done in my two previous of,
well no you have not. But it seems, you know,
it's easy to think that you did that, but with Dave, um,
you know,
there's enough moments where he's misstepped where they just feel like,
okay, we got a wounded antelope. Yeah, they're trying to pick him off.
And you know,
I think there was probably a move to do Shapiro and there was a period where you
were seemingly in the cross hairs but your heart to kill. And you know,
I have no doubt that I was in the crosshairs. I wouldn't even notice it. See,
that's the, that's the benefit of not paying attention.
And this is something that I've been pretty rigorous about over the last six
months or years to Sam Harris and Dave Ruben have all given me versions of this
advice.
And I worry about it because I'm not large enough yet that I've been the target
of a steady campaign.
But what happens is you see people's feedback loops interrupted and in part to
course correct, you kind of want to know what's like,
was I too harsh with that guy?
Like when I went on with Jordan Peterson a on Dave show,
I was more aggressive because I think I'd seen Jordan and Brett on your show
together. And, uh, I come from an ethnic family, we interrupt each other,
that's normal and Jordan is an interrupter. And so, um,
what I found is,
is that I probably was intuiting that I had to be more forceful and a lot of the
comments. Wow. Eric, I haven't really seen you this aggressive.
Was there three of you on the conversation?
It started off Dave Jordan and myself and then Ben Shapiro came in for an hour
and I think Sam Harris might've been, uh, scheduled to come in. I don't know.
Remember there's an issue always with more than one person.
There's a reason why I do one-on-ones almost exclusively. Like,
even when I had Bob Lasar with Jeremy Corbell, uh, just,
just having a third person that wants to chime in like oftentimes interrupts the
flow of conversation.
Like in that case it was because I wanted to lock in on Bob Lasar, right.
I wanted to get all my feedback. I want to find out is this guy full of shit?
Like what I want, I want to lock in with them.
And there's another button and also, and also this is another person.
Even if they have a good thing to say, it's a distraction. It becomes a problem.
You never know when one of these is going to work. And when one of the,
when it works, it can be magical. And when yes, when it doesn't, you know,
it's a little bit like jazz guys.
If that group is meant to be,
then they don't trip over each other solos that are trying to come up with
something. Even with three great friends, I have this issue.
I mean it just some great stuff with multiple people on your show.
And I've seen stuff that doesn't work. And you know, the other,
the other night we had, um, uh,
Brian Callan is fast becoming one of my favorite people in the world and he had
us over. Um, and it was really fascinating.
It was all guys who could rip your head off, not your head off.
They could certainly rip my head off and very thoughtful ones at that.
There were people from all different ethnicities. My wife was the only female.
And one of the things I found astounding was that everybody was taking the piss
out of each other. And it was the most intimate, positive,
loving kind of, uh,
an environment you could imagine where people are joking about each other's
ethnicity, their religion.
And I had to remind myself about how men actually manage intimacy and closeness.
And it's not the way women do it and appreciate on each other and we shit on
each other. And it's frigging important to how we do business.
And increasingly I have this idea that I need that in my life. Well,
we have to check each other to see if each other's taking each other seriously.
You have to make sure you're not taking yourself too seriously.
I didn't feel like lots of jokes were made at my expense.
I was probably the only guy there who wasn't, you know, uh,
some form of a combat, uh, sport veteran. And, you know,
there were a couple of jokes at my expense on that.
There were a couple of Jewish jokes. I felt terrific leaving that place.
There was no part of me that felt like, wow, I really got Hayes,
but I hope I got through it. I mean,
these guys were just so positive and generous of spirit.
And Brian is one of the best of that. He's so silly.
Like most of his podcasts that he does with me and him have pretty cool
podcasts. We've known each other for ever.
We've been best friends since 1994. Is that right? Yeah,
I mean guys, that guy is smart.
I love him so much that I broke up with this girl. And, uh, Brian,
um, she was, she was calling me because she was horny and I was like, look,
I have a new girlfriend but I have a friend. Oh, fuck you.
And he's just like me.
So this I sick Brian on my ex girlfriend and he fucked her.
One of the funniest conversations I ever had with an ex girlfriend.
She calls me up and she goes, your friend came inside me and I went, what?
She goes, yeah, your fucking friend came inside me. And I was like, well,
did you tell him that you were on the pill? She goes, no, no,
I'm not on the pill. And I was like, well, I don't know what to tell you.
You know, that's prion. You guys should have worked that out.
But I'm an ex girlfriend.
Call you up mad because your friend ejaculated inside of her.
It was one of the most, I hung up the phone.
I literally fell to the ground laughing.
I was lying on my back on the floor and my house going
like, it's just so ridiculous as Brian Callan, Brian Cal, everywhere.
So I called him up and I said, did you, what happened? And he's like, whoops.
It was just such a ridiculous conversation.
But I've been friends with that guy forever. So all of our conversations,
so like that.
I see all of our conversations are like jokes and hazing and shitting on each
other. But it's all hugs and love. I mean I'm just so positive and generous.
And you know, one funny thing,
I was looking at his Instagram and he's seated next to, I don't know it.
I can't remember it. Was it Cheetah? I'll say to a wild cheetah. Yeah.
And he's talking about how you have sex with it.
I like to get up in the morning, perhaps we will hug together.
I smell antelope nearby. He's clarity. There's an extra,
a real cheetah. Yeah, Cheetahs are interesting. Then you can actually pet them.
It's weird. I didn't know it was a game reserve.
I see like a one of the items so far. No, no, no.
I mean a lot of that is in Africa. I'm not in terms of like, like they're,
they're not pets. Yeah, but they're so used to people.
Cause people were always going on safari there and apparently you can get real
close to them in some environments. But Cheetahs in particular,
a lot of people keep them as pets. Like you see like a lot of sheikhs,
like rich guys in the Middle East.
They'll be driving around and their fucking AMG wagons with a,
a cheetah next to them, cheat on a leash and the cheetahs just cool with it.
See nobody, nobody, nobody does that with hippos.
I think if you want to go next level, yeah, that wouldn't work out.
Hippos just decided to fuck you up. Yeah. What is with us in the hippos,
hippos are like, they're a cousin, two pigs and then they're right. Yeah.
They're a ruthless fucking animal. Oh, now I see it. They don't play any games.
Yeah, and for Vegetarians it's not even like that where their food,
they are vegetarians, but they do eat meat. I know their kid will soda deer,
you know, deer and cows, they'll eat birds. I can.
We're not going back into that vampire deer thing that, no, no.
Freaked me out last time. But dear often times eat birds.
The ground nesting birds. There's a lot of video of it.
Like people don't want to believe it. They think that, you know,
they just eat grass most of the time they do.
But they will eat a bird if they get a chance, you know, they know it's food.
Yeah. It's weird. Yeah.
And they have an herbivores that just have track but they'll still eat a bird.
There's a lot of videos. Deer.
I guess I've been really fascinated by the number of species in which some human
like totally deadly species where some human is decided I'm going to dedicate my
life to hanging out and not getting eaten. Hyenas,
there's some asshole that a is uh, he's, he's hanging out with hyenas on the,
on the internet and pet them. They, they seem really playful and friendly.
Real sweet thrill. Weird. This guy is like nuzzling these hyenas.
Imagine choosing the high. That's your system. I said,
that is an animal that bites so fucking hard. They have,
they have like one of the strongest bites ever measured because their,
their whole thing is just smashing bones and trying to get out the nutrition
that the lions leave behind. So they're all just about crushing bones.
So their whole face is designed to smash bones. Yeah.
And you know, they're, they're fucking, so here's the guy,
he's hanging out with these hyenas. He plays with them. Look at this asshole.
But they, they're playing with them. They're,
they seem to think he's like their buddy. Look, they're all there biting him,
but they're gentle. I mean they get rip his arm clean off,
but they're biting his leg and you know, he's nuzzling with them.
He's letting you write his face. I do not know. I do not know.
Cause I think a lot of these have to do with imprinting. Oh yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
Well that was the thing with my friend Phil Demars who worked at marine land.
One of the reasons why he's so furious at damage,
cause he's got a walrus named smooshing and the Walrus imprinted with him when
it was really young. But walrus thinks that's his mom. Okay.
That he's rather the Walrus. His mom, you know,
so he's just on this fucking furious quest to get this walrus released and to
shut down the shit hole known as marine land. Yeah.
He's been sued forever.
He's been involved in lawsuits as long as I've known him and he's been coming on
this podcast for years, for years.
We've been trying to boost his signal and trying to get the word out.
And then when blackfish came out that sort of really turned the tide where
people got a chance to see what Orca captivities really like.
And they were like, Holy Shit, this is horrific. It is absolutely barbaric.
But, um, anyway, his, uh, that's, that's uh, his,
this wall was come from him. He gave me that. It's cool that, yeah,
that sits there for Phil, that, that sits on the desk for Phil who is,
who is the, uh, Hall of fame here in the desk. Is there a camera over there? Oh,
this is, um, this, uh, these are all little, um,
little,
little statuettes from a company called Plasta cell [inaudible] and a plastic
cell is, how do you say phone's name? Fom Tran.
He's an amazing artist who's created all of these. A little, little,
little figurines. This is Rory McDonald who's a elite UFC fighter.
Bruce Lee, notorious B. I g. That's my dog. Marshall Marshall has one.
That's me, a Tupac, Conor McGregor, Kanye.
And then that is a different one. The bobblehead one that's rich rebuilds.
He's got this really dope um, uh,
really dope website or youtube channel where he,
he's the only guy that I know of that's ever rebuilt a Tesla.
He bought a wreck,
Tesla and then bought another one and put the parts together and figured out how
to make it work. And the Tesla people do not like him.
They don't like these doing that.
And now he's made a place called the electrified garage in Massachusetts where
he is working on Tesla's in electric vehicles outside of their ecosystem.
So he's doing it on his own, like an independent way. Slum, Massachusets,
you think he's going to hybridize with Boston dynamics? No,
he's an independent guy. That would be cool. He's not,
how do you say his last name? Ben Wa right. It's been, it looks like Benoit,
but it's been wa very cool guy. He was on the podcast recently. Hey,
what happened?
What do we know about the Kanye situation where he's going to talk about mental
health? I was kind of excited about that. I, you know, if he wants to,
he can do it. I'm not, yeah, don't, he's, he's, uh, he's his own thing.
He is a brilliant artist,
but oftentimes with brilliant artists, it's not,
this is not the best format for them to just talk.
Like sometimes it's better for them to express themselves through their work.
Maybe. Although I found, you know,
I spent two days with him and I found that when he's in a relaxed,
um, frame, his flow state is just, it's beautiful. Well,
I enjoy talking to him. I talked to him on the phone.
I really enjoyed our conversation and a nice conversation. He said,
I think he's a very good dude. Very sensitive Human Viagra. Very cool guy.
But this is Donald relaxed environment. You know this right here,
everybody knows how many people are listening.
It's just if fuck people's head up really.
Cause the illusion that I have is just you and me talking and then I come out of
here and people are like, what did you do? You said, well you and I are friends.
So that illusion is more maintained when you don't know me and you come in and I
mean I would have to be friends with him,
but so that's one of the things he wanted me to come to his church. You know,
he's got, he's running a cult essentially. Everybody's wearing white.
They're all dancing and doing religious stuff. I do that. Yeah. Busy man.
So you're busy Sundays. Your family time is your family. Well I'm not into,
I just, I get it. I think it's beautiful, you know, but I'm not,
he and I were walking down the road and you know,
there was this crippler which has got the crib crips from Long Beach. He said,
you know, Kanye, you better stay in Calabasas.
It was like a little bit of a tense situation. So
we're walking along the road and like,
people were hanging out of the windows of their car. You're like, God, Yay.
And I think it was just like positive, you know, like when I make contact.
But it was very disconcerting and this guy was preternaturally call,
you know, he was just like [inaudible]. I was nervous. How long ago is this?
This was, you remember when you went on TMZ? Well, the,
the we talking a year or less. I think it was probably a year ago.
It's probably medicated. Not Anymore. Oh, is that right? Yeah. Yeah.
He talked openly about the fact that last six months or so he's been off of his
medication and he,
whatever they had him on was fucking with him creatively. Well, do you remember,
um,
all of her sex had this chapter in the man who mistook his wife for a hat about
a drummer with Tourette's syndrome now.
And then he took a drug to control the Tourette's syndrome and the guy's
drumming became kind of monotonous. Very regular, but like not creative.
Yeah. You look the, what that guy has gotten inside of him.
He's so prolific. I mean, you listen to his music,
it's so interesting and eclectic and prolific and he's just constantly turning
out more great shit. He doesn't have any flops.
I mean his music is pretty fucking amazing and he's just, that's his shit man.
He knows how to just get in there and create and he's got this whirlwind going
on in his mind. He's fearless. He's,
he is explore and only get into the details.
But one of the things that really impressed me was he would go to places that
I'm too scared to go to in my own mind and just, Oh, just, you know,
thinking about your inadequacies and externalizing them and your vulnerabilities
and knowing, you know, what is going to emasculate you.
And his point is like,
I'm so comfortable with myself that I'm going to mind that as a source of art
because I bet it's in everyone. And you know,
by exploring these contradictions and these false fronts and you know,
he's, he's kind of a level of internal access.
I'm actually quite interested in the mental health aspect of this,
which is there's so much w,
so much mental unhealth as we as we term it,
that I don't think it's all mental unhealth.
I do think that there's something about the artistic process that seems to be
very informed by states that we call in health. Yeah,
well we require people to stay inside these rigid boundaries and these rigid
boundaries there.
They're great if you want to show up at a job and work nine to five and don't
use certain noises with your mouth because it makes people upset, you know?
But that's not for the creative process.
If you look at true outliers,
if you want to discuss true outliers like people that are really capable of
producing extraordinary art or architecture
did different interesting things that are part of the creative process.
Those people are all unwell, every single one of them.
I mean in terms of like if you made them do what a normal person has to do every
day. I think normal life is unwell in terms of this,
this requirement of showing up five minutes early,
working all day long, getting off, maybe bringing some of your work home,
getting some sleep, getting up in the morning and doing it all over again.
All why raising a family and trying to enjoy your time,
your limited finite time on this planet. Well,
this is why I said I've left. Oh, so you left is that it's not healthy here.
So where are you? Well, um, maybe,
maybe this is a good segue, I hadn't thought about it this way, but, um,
so can we use this format to, uh,
announce that I am in fact starting the podcast?
I've recorded a couple boom episodes already, uh,
that are in the cannon. It is, it is called the portal. The portal. Yeah.
So the portal is, um, refers to this,
this very interesting, uh, thing that I,
I thought everyone was aware of, but very often people would react to it.
When I was a kid,
I read all of these stories that I thought were known to be the same story,
but different versions of it. And I called it the portal story.
And it was always the same.
Somebody is trapped in a humdrum existence in an ordinary world until some sort
of magical portal accidentally or on purpose enters their life.
And either they go through a wardrobe, they go through a rabbit hole,
the looking glass platform, nine and three quarters, um,
or you know, Dorothy famously, uh,
was used to introduce technicolor where she, the first part of the film,
she's in Kansas and it's in sort of gray scale, black and white. Oh,
that's right.
And then she lands and Oz and they opened the door and it's technicolor.
And there's this transitional scene, um,
where you see technicolor for the first time.
Was that the first time I ever in a movie? I believe so and so,
and so the question is, um, where's the portal?
Like why do we tell the same story over and over and over again with different
protagonists? But it's always the same formula.
It's somebody is trapped in an ordinary world. They're sort of,
there were around normies.
They find the portal and the portal becomes the call to adventure and they spend
time in the alternate universe.
And then somehow they're able to live very often they return. Uh,
if you remember the phantom tollbooth,
Milo gets this present of a car in a tollbooth and he goes through the toll
booth and he, uh,
I see Norton gesture was the author and Jules Feiffer
was the deal illustrations. It was just this brilliant book, uh,
where there's like the land of letters in the land of numbers.
So it's arts and sciences and you know, like there's a,
there's a person who starts from his head and grows down until his feet reached
the ground and there's a number's mine.
And he has to rescue the princesses of rhyme and reason in order to restore
order between the two kingdoms of the United,
like left and right hemisphere in some incredibly, uh,
exciting story. And the idea is that after he goes and does all of these,
like there's an island called conclusions. And when you make an assumption,
you leap to conclusions, so you suddenly jump. I mean, it's,
it's all very clever. Wordplay. And stuff. At the end of the adventure,
the toll booth disappears because it has to go to the next kid who needs it,
you know? And so my question was always, why?
Why on earth would we tell the same story over and over and over and over and
over again? It has the same format and it's always a different context.
And I came to believe that this story is actually this unkept promise for most
people that in their adult lives, they don't find these portals.
So for example, have you ever been to Barcelona, Spain? No.
There is a church in Barcelona, Spain,
which is plenty impressive from the outside when you go inside,
I've been looking at pictures of my entire life called La Sagrada Familia.
It is a psychedelic drug trip and a half like you've never seen.
It is the most bizarre interior space I've ever seen in my life.
Can you bring up the interior of this thing? Wow.
And on the one hand it induces like a hallucinogenic state.
On the other hand, it's an idea of what this architect gouty.
Now Goudy is very famous. He did a lot of buildings around Barcelona.
There is nothing like the inside of this church on this planet.
And um, wow,
fuck, that's beautiful. And if you look up at the roof,
wow,
okay.
And like, you know, most things,
you're sort of prepared for them your whole life and then you see it and you
think, Eh, Eh, I guess, I guess that's cool.
I'd been seeing this thing my whole life and I had no,
no concept of what a genius this human being was because nothing he did,
um, go to the outside of it, the outside of it. I mean, look, this guy,
if he never did the inside of this church,
he would be a very famous and idiosyncratic architect. Wow.
But are they doing work on it there? They haven't finished it yet. In fact,
he's such a,
he's such a genius that they can't finish it in the style that he started it
because nobody knows. It's like an unfinished symphony. What would you do?
Nobody's smart enough to finish the this church. Wow. Look at that roof on that.
Okay. Now that is a portal that is a portal, right?
And when we, when,
when I was on this program before, you know, I thought long and hard,
what is it that I could push out to the planet to let people know how wonderful
and beautiful the world that we live in is?
And we pushed out the hop vibration and suddenly if you were caught,
I said to people, this is the most important object in the universe.
Not The hop vibration in particular, but the class called the principle bundle,
which people have no idea it's out there and it is the basis of the construct in
which we live.
So how is it that a normal human being can make contact with real physics,
uh, with, you know, real beauty of biology or you know,
just understanding order, symmetry,
all of these things that are beyond normal experience. And
what I hope to do with the podcast is to have amazing guests and interesting
conversations, but to, oh, thank you for that Jack. I was on drugs.
That guy was, he was drunk. Yeah. Well that's, you know,
remember that's what Dolly said. Somebody said, Dolly, do you take drugs?
He said, I am drunk. Right? Another Spaniards. Spaniards are really something.
But that
is very similar to psychedelic states.
Well, maybe some people have access to them all the time, right? In part, well,
there's a, there's actually no
duration.
It sits above our sink out there from a guy who has a tumor in his pituitary or
is a nice pituitary gland. His, um,
uh, what is the one that, that the one that they think producers. DMT.
What the fuck is it called? Not The pituitary gland. Now.
Pineal pioneer. Thank you.
He has a tumor in his [inaudible] tumor in his pineal gland. And so he,
he accesses these states all the time. So this guy has,
it's 100% DMT inspired artwork. I mean, if you look at it,
that's like what you see when you do DMT trips. It's like, it's a version,
you know, and in his style of art. But you can see the,
you can see the signature of DMT. There it is. There's his artwork.
What is his name? Sean Thornton. Sean Thorton. Thank you Sean.
Thanks for the artwork. It's fucking awesome. And it sits in our kitchen.
I'll take a picture of it later and put it online. But, um,
that's his stuff like that. Super DMT, like, oh, that's amazing. I mean,
that's a thing, a trip to mean type a experience at, you know,
like you could say like Alex Gray, uh,
is probably the most representative I would say.
He's the most representative in terms of artists in the,
the DMT space in terms of like, uh,
tryptamines and siliciden and things along those lines.
And so if you think about, um,
psychoactive chemicals, some of them are stupefying,
but some of them are portals.
And this concept of if you look at a wall,
how do you know that the wall doesn't have a door?
How do you know that there isn't a panic room behind the bookcase if you've just
pull out the right book? We are,
we learned to stop looking for the portal. And I think what I,
what I do differently than other people is that I became obsessed with exits.
That there are other worlds and they're real, that this,
this mythology of the looking glass.
And the rabbit hole and the Matrix is metaphor for very real things and that we
just,
we live our lives in the most ordinary mesoscale phenomenon where, you know,
we don't see, um,
we don't see the quantum because we're not, you know,
playing with polarized lenses in ways that show us what light actually is.
Um, you know, we're not playing with super fluid helium. We're not uh,
understanding, um,
just how bizarre olfaction is or you know,
whether there is some sort of quantum aspect of biology and what you see people
doing is that they're, they, they start grasping for everything.
Like I'm not saying that there's nothing to ancient aliens or UFOs or whatever,
but a lot of that is just people want something richer and more,
more amazing for their lives.
And I'm not going to pass too much judgment on that,
but I am going to say if we just restricted the,
the rest of our days to the provable stuff that we know is out there,
it could be amazing.
People need more meaning with all of the rationality,
with all of the mystery we've taken out of the world.
It's time to put a ton of it back in.
When you say put, put a ton of it back in like, hey,
how are you going to put it back in? Well, um, you know,
if I were to start talking about the October,
Ian's an eight dimensional number system that no one understands,
I can do that totally rigorously.
I can show you all sorts of bizarre stuff involving the October eons.
What is the October? Well, that's my point.
You don't even know that there are four types of numbers.
Who's dance, uh,
called the real numbers that we know complex numbers that were tortured once
with in high school, maybe during some kind of a trip.
A friend of you mentioned, the court mentioned the quaternions to you,
and then there's this one system of numbers, uh,
which is like the crazy relative nobody discusses and that's called the October
ones. And the October ones are so weird that mathematicians don't even really
understand why they're there. That's an octomom that thing. Well,
my guess is that that's probably back to the root lattice of v Eight which we
discussed last time, which has this kind of Mandela pattern to it. But,
um, I could show you their multiplication table.
I could describe their cemeteries. There's a symmetry group called two,
which involves these strange numbers, but it's a mystery. Like if I got to,
I probably know more about the [inaudible] than most mathematicians.
If I got to the end of all of my knowledge of the Octoni eons,
I still wouldn't know what to tell you about why they're there and what they
mean. Nobody knows. I promise you that
that's a real mystery. Now we could talk about like, you know,
my friend said that that event that happened in Siberia in the early, you know,
20th century was actually an alien visitation. Well, maybe best, maybe no,
I don't know anything about it.
If I just focused us on like what we know is out there that we don't grasp,
which is 100% rock solid,
it provides so much mystery and meaning and invitation to adventure. Like,
if you're looking for a hero's journey, I'll show you a ton of these things.
And it's empowering. It's just incredibly, um,
it's incredibly empowering to know that you're a hair's breath away from
superpowers. So I want to help people explore that. Oh,
so what is that like when you're explaining this,
when you're saying this is bizarre series of numbers, right? What is it doing?
Like what, how, how do we interface with it? Well, um,
so for example, let's,
let's take an easier system that we feel a little bit more confident with.
There's this thing called the quaternions, which are based on the number one,
the complex number. I,
if you remember that from some distant math class,
and then there's something called j and k.
So I Times j equals k j times cake was I j times I is equal to the negative of I
times j. So negative k, there's a multiplication table for these,
these objects.
And these objects help with computer vision. You know,
computers, uh, simulation 3d, uh, projections,
they're used all the time in, um, probably video games.
They may come up in nature. I mean,
we know that nature uses complex numbers and most people never found out why
they were being told about complex numbers or imaginary numbers because they
never got to the point where you're actually looking at wave functions that
described photons and electrons and all of all of that good stuff that you read
about in physics. So in essence, um,
the Octoni eons are a system where I,
j k keeps going effectively through element on PQR, you know,
till you've got eight different objects and they're not even associative,
which is one of these rules that you learned about, like, you know,
multiplication as associative and you think, well, what is an associative,
right? So if I, you know, if you, if you talk about community, for example,
I can't tell whether you put on your shirt, uh,
first or your shoes first because it's,
it's communitive as to which order you did it.
But if you put on your underwear in a different order than you put on your
pants, that'll become immediately obvious which order you did it. Right. Okay.
Well,
there's another thing called associativity and almost everything that we deal
with in elementary mathematics is associative. So you're like,
why do I learn about associativity?
I've never met anything that isn't associated. Well, the OCTONI and associates,
they're a number system that is responsible for most of the Plat,
a pie of mathematics, if you will, things that just occur.
Anomalously so that's an example of an invitation out of this planet.
You know,
if you start to think about the Octoni ans and care about them and say,
are they a message? Do they have meaning? We can prove that they're there,
construct them for you,
but they generate so much bizarreness in some sort of abstract space.
How are they recognized? Like how, how was it,
how did it come to be that this was a point of discussion? Well, there's,
there's a process. In fact,
there are two processes where you can build these number systems up from each
other. So you build the complex from the real,
you build the quaternions from the complex,
you build the October Ian's from the quaternions and then you can't build
anything beyond that because each time you're giving up a magical power to get
to the next stage.
And by the time you get to the Octoni and you're exhausted the system giving
them a magical power. Well like for example, um,
it's very hard to think about the square root of negative one.
So like what does it mean for something squared to be negative?
So that's like the complex numbers gave up, that kind of sensibility.
And then the complex numbers, or at least community a times B equals B times a,
but the quaternions don't have that price property.
So then you have a further property called associativity.
So you're sort of to eat, to build the next system.
You're giving up properties that sort of make sense to us.
And by the time you've gotten to the act, Tony, you've given everything away.
There's no way you're going to build the next system. But yet it's real. Yes.
Yet it's real in a, in a, in a, in a very real mathematical sense.
So does it just highlight our lack of understanding? Yeah.
And it is a call to adventure.
It's like a message from something that isn't human.
I'm not going to say that it's God.
I'm not going to say that it's logic or design, but it's a more complex,
it's something to them of the universe. That's right.
And you have to uncover that these things are there. Or for example, you know,
see elegance. I don't know if you've like played with the,
do you know about c elegans? No. Alright. CLEC elegance.
C letter elegance. And again,
elegans. I think it's okay.
So it's this worm that was chosen by this guy, Sydney Brenner,
who just died and it's a shame because he would've been a great podcast guest,
just like one of the most brilliant biologists that we didn't focus on.
And he said, you know what?
We're missing a species that we can completely describe soup to nuts.
Here's the one that's about the simplest thing with the brain.
It's only got a thousand cells and 300 of those cells make up a very primitive
neuro system and we're going to track where every goddamn cell like bring up
Jamie, if I could ask you, so to bring up the cell
lineage diagram for sea elegans.
So this will be the first of two images. Wow.
That is a complete map of how one fertilized egg becomes
a tiny microscopic worm for every possible division.
What the fuck am I looking at?
I love when you say that, that is so wild right now.
Here's the thing.
Everyone in biology knows how cool this thing is and very few people,
not enough people outside of biology know that we have completely mapped how one
cell, like if you're 30 trillion cells around,
it's too big to write a diagram.
It's only possible because there are only a thousand cells and this thing has
locomotion. It has sexual reproduction, you know it eats.
So you're looking at the architectural plans for an actual organism and Jamie,
when we're done with that,
if I could trouble you for the look for the folks that are just falling,
kind of pause free for a moment.
For the folks that are falling at home listening, just listening,
not watching what we're looking at. Jamie,
explain how someone could see this image if they want to go with themselves.
The letter C,
it's not the not see like the ocean to see elegance and then that cell lineage,
it looks like a really long basketball bracket. Yes. Pushed out forever.
That's a good way to describe it. Yeah, it's fucking wild.
Yeah. Talk about March madness
madness, June men February. It just doesn't stop.
If we could bring up the um,
wiring diagram or adjacency matrix. Yeah,
let's see how it gets wired oriented. All right. Yeah. Perfect.
That is a complete map of the 300 neurons in the sea elegans worm.
How they are wired to each other. Like that is a map of the mind of the worm.
Wow. Okay. So that's the portal.
That's another portal.
Here's an organism which is completely mapped and has complex behaviors.
It has, I think about half the number of adult cell types that you and I have,
so maybe we have like 250 had like only 250 different kinds of adult cells,
more or less. I don't want to get too precise about that
and yet we are like 10 trillion or 30 trillion copies of those tiny number of
different types of cells.
Whether I think the sea elegans has about 125 or something like that,
different cell types and it only has a thousand cells and it's able to do most
of what we're able to do. We move around, we eat,
we have sex, right? Pretty simple life. Do you think
it's ever possible? Well, let's, I'm sure it's probably possible,
but do you think in our lifetime we'll ever see a map like that of a human
organism? I don't think so,
but the cool thing is we have this map and we still don't understand it.
Like we've got this thing dead to rights. We've got it boxed in. It can't.
We know every single cell, what it does,
we have all the wirings between the neurons and we still don't get it.
Right, right. So like imagine that your, what,
eight years that, well, what did, what did genius,
this Guy Sydney Brenner was for choosing this organism [inaudible] right.
Because this organism is the simplest place to look at complex life.
[inaudible] this image of the reconstructed biological neural networks.
Like you're looking, okay,
now we could have a discussion about some weird Peruvian structure and whether
we'd been visited [inaudible] and I'd be up for that. Look,
I to pretend that I'm too good for it, but I know that this is real.
I don't have any doubt. I'm not going to sit around asking, well,
do you believe that, you know,
aliens talk to this federal government in the forties, right. Um,
that might as well be an alien. Yeah. And it's an invitation to adventure. Yeah.
And we are destroying. I mean, you know, getting,
just getting back to it,
the reason that I'm fighting through culture war issues,
which are not very interesting to me,
is that we are destroying the thing that has the ability to make sense of the
world. Right? It's really designed in logic. What I mean,
like the ability to say no. You know, you come with an experiment that failed,
you know, and you say, I think it succeeded. I say, no it didn't. It failed.
And you say, well,
I actually am a Cambodian and I think you're discriminating against me because
I'm Cambodian. It's like, look, your experiment failed.
It has nothing to do with Cambodian, you know,
and you keep that stuff out of my lap. I mean,
if you want your war stuff, yeah.
Really what I'm animated by is get your fucking social engineering out of my
laboratory. You've got 10 minutes and I'm calling security. That's my issue.
It's not telling people how to behave or that I have all the answers or that we
need to be objective in our lives and we just want to have sensible discussions.
It's,
you're coming after core reality and our ability to make sense of the world.
And so I'm happy to entertain all sorts of things.
You take one foot step, one foot in my lab and I'm calling security.
And if I can't do that,
if I can't maintain a scientific journal or a university in which the bullshit
departments do not invade,
the departments that are actually doing the super important work were lost.
And there is a distinction
and I mean, this distinction needs to be made there.
There is a distinction between hard science and gender studies.
If you could put, pull up Jamie. Um,
let's do the, uh, anomalous magnetic moment of the electron.
Oh, you can do, yeah. You went all Sean Connery on me. One raise the eyebrow.
Yeah. One eyebrow. Isn't that like a genetic thing?
Like you can curl your tongue like, hey, I could do that.
Some people can't do that at [inaudible]. [inaudible]
what do you mean turned upside down? Oh No, I can't do that. All right.
You've got one thing. I got another. Okay. This is a very mature Joe. Huh?
Um, what, what is it going on here? Um, put a Sig,
I'm looking for a number with like 10 or 11 significant digits.
Um,
we are able to do calculations in quantum electrodynamics let's say a quantum
field theory in which we can figure out the precision of some thing.
We can predict it to like 10 or 11 decimal places of accuracy.
And when I look at the,
the achievement that was necessary to have theory agree with experiment to that
level.
And then I listened to some of the discussions about, oh,
just take these hoaxes about, you know, uh,
somebody who submitted parts of mine comp to a, you know,
as with Jews re written as men, Peter, but right.
Those two subjects are taking place in the same institution.
One is incredibly rigorous and demanding and completely unforgiving.
And the other thing is just like prevalence and nonsense. Well,
maybe there's a core of it that makes sense, but there's,
it's not going to get anywhere close to the achievements of the,
of the hard sciences. But the core of it, whether or not it makes sense,
the real problem is the motivation for doing it in the first place. Well,
the real motivation may be activism,
but Activision activism and scholarship aren't,
I mean there's so many things that I want to be true that just aren't,
I want beautiful. I mean like you know, nature, you spend time in nature,
you want to think, you know,
like nature's a community and where the forest is a bunch of different organisms
all working together. No, it's red of tooth and claw.
Everything that you think about the universe that is purely beautiful and
aspirational is contradicted by some system in nature.
And that's why evolutionary theory was the first thing on the chopping block.
It's just like, well,
this contradicts everything we want to claim about organisms. Well, tough luck.
I feel like there's a way to define this clearly that makes people understand it
better. Okay. And I don't, I don't know if I'm the guy to do it, but I feel like
there's a, this is an incredibly complex issue,
right?
Where you're dealing with emotions and feelings and people who feel like there's
unjustice in the world and inequality and they focus on those things to the
point where they're almost participating in social engineering by ignoring
reality and focusing on what they want to be true in sort of this way of
reimagining the world and they are also demanding compliance.
This is a big part of this whole thing that's going on here.
Then on the other hand,
you've got this stuff yet these hard sciences that demand just regular,
rigorous intellectual debate.
They demand careful study of the facts. They demand
deep understanding of complex mathematics in order to achieve these results and
to be able to verify them. They're unforgiving, unforgiving. There's just,
they're two totally different things and then what you're saying is when one of
them that is this sort of for frivolous,
airy,
kind of Utopian version of what they liked the future to be and then interferes,
right, where they want a certain amount of diverse people on the staff and
not even saying that it's frivolous. I'm not even saying it's not scholarship.
I'm saying that whatever it is, I don't care. Maybe,
maybe it's maybe it's some beautiful social thing.
What do you do? But then they'll hit you with,
you don't care because you're a white male and you have white male privilege
and I don't. And what I realize is is that as important in as inclusion is,
exclusion is equally important. And the instant you say that, I don't know you,
the time of day, what does that mean by exclusion? Equally important,
we keep talking about diversity and inclusion, diversity, inclusion, diversity,
inclusion. And there's an implicit threat in that,
which is what makes it really juicy and interesting, which is like, well,
let's look at us. We've got three white guys in here, this, Jamie, you and me.
So speak to yourself. I'm 1.6% African. Recognize that I knew he was good.
I knew he was going to play that card, but you sir can pass as white, right?
Yes. Okay.
Now in order to have the objection,
like there's some little bit of guilt, which is like, well,
why aren't there any people from Cambodia in here? Is that that we are,
we're really anti Cambodian. Um, if you carry that guilt,
you're always worried that you have to be able to prove that you're inclusive.
It doesn't matter. Right? Right. Okay.
It is also important to exclude certain voices from the conversation.
So the voice that plays the card, which says, well,
you're only saying that because x, I don't have to listen to that voice.
And I think this is really important.
That is not a voice that needs to be answered. It's not a voice
that, um,
needs to be taken seriously or paid attention to unless there's some serious
allegation that there has been some kind of discrimination or inclusion.
The burden of proof is on you for saying why that's interesting.
And a particular conversation.
The burden is on you to explain why that's interesting. Right.
Well, for them, they're trying to engineer a more fair and balanced society.
If I was gonna take their perspective,
they would say that the reason why there aren't more women in science or Trans
People in science or you know, fill,
and I'm also trying to engineer a world where there are more women in science.
How are you doing that?
By trying to figure out what is it that selecting against women, for example,
that we need to get women more money, as I said,
on this program earlier in their lives so they can hire help to help raise their
children so they can spend more time on their careers and balance. Um,
yeah, but a lot of women don't find that attractive. They don't want to do that.
Maybe. But I'm trying to think. But my point is,
is that there are lots of reasons that men and women are different, right? Yeah.
So for example, um,
I saw a beautiful video of a guy who jumps down an enormous flight of stairs on
a skateboard and he just nails the landing and it's just a, it's a thing of art.
And then it shows you 150 attempts where this guy just abused his body.
And failed and failed, maybe broke a tooth, you know,
blood everywhere and you're thinking,
oh you showed me the success and you didn't show me that this guy was willing to
put his brain, his life on the line in order to nail that trick.
And he's actually one of the world's falling champions. Right? Okay.
Well when you start saying, well,
why are you putting this video of this person who's doing this thing, you know,
on the Internet because that person belongs to a privileged class. I'm saying,
well I don't know that guy abused himself and put himself at risk and you know,
devoted his life in a singular way that no sensible PR. I mean I would be,
I would be appalled if my son did that. I'd be furious with it. No,
there are things that are,
that are happening that result in imbalances that aren't about some kind of
unfairness.
And I think it's very important to say that unfairness is real and structural
problems are real and non structural problems and things that really aren't
unfair are also real.
I think we both agree that it's important for people to have the opportunity to
pursue what they enjoy pursuing.
I think there's also an issue where we want people to be more represented.
We want more of that,
that kind of person that's interested in something when they might not
necessarily naturally gravitate towards it. And it not be
that there are some impediments and that there's some boundaries and some,
some sort of a boys club that keeps them out and it might be more that they're
just not that interested in that.
They're all sorts of biologically that's been proven in studies that I'm trying
to make it a different point. Right. Okay. To me, what I'm
trying to say is, I made a mistake years ago,
I think of engaging in answering this point, which is,
you know, let's say let's take piano competitions.
Why are piano competitions historically a disproportionately, you know,
uh, let's say entered in one by Russians or chess or who knows what? Well,
Russians are beasts in the way that they destroy children on their way to the
concert stage.
They will do things that most American families will not do to produce a concert
pianist. Okay. That's not an unfairness for the rest of us. I mean,
I play the piano.
I can't get on stage with these guys because they're just amazing. It's not,
it's not an unfairness that I'm not represented on that stage.
Um, you know, if I told you that I'm,
my intention is to become the world's greatest, uh,
Jujitsu expert at age 53. Being overweight and not having, uh,
any history in combat sports. You know,
and I know that it's not going to happen with the right amount of drugs.
Come on, Joe
and engineering. We can do miraculous things. That's true.
We can make him better than he was. Yeah. We need 'em daily stem cells.
We're gonna, we're going to have to do some real,
cause we're gonna take a chance on cancer and all sorts of other diseases.
We can, we can achieve some things. Okay.
But the previous conversation that we're going, no, you need to develop.
You need to develop it. It needs to be a part of your, well,
here's the thing that I always say about a striking sports.
Striking sports are probably one of the more interesting ones in that when you
start out at an early age,
your body develops learning how to strike and it's a gigantic advantage over
someone who learns once they're past puberty.
When you get someone who's learning how to strike and they're in their twenties
it takes a real outlier to become super successful. It's very,
very rare. But I remember
being in a fist fight and throwing a punch and not connecting and hurting my
arm. It was like, oh, I didn't understand if you, it's not free.
You know, it's like a very, it's a very expensive. Now all you've got,
this is your left arm and you got a really pissed off person, a across from you.
Um,
what I was getting back to is I wanted to talk about in part the portal and how
it relates to the whole sort of weird social justice thing.
The key point is, I'm not that interested in the culture wars.
I'm interested in the pipeline of amazing stuff that is unforgiving.
Right? But don't you think that along the way you have to kind of address it?
The culture wars are a thing. Try to figure out why they're a thing.
Trying to figure out what,
what are the main points and main factors that are responsible for it being a
thing?
And is there a way to mitigate its impact on progress? Well, this is,
I'm concerned that the culture wars are going to be
keep girls, black people, whoever,
short people. I don't know what out of the things that they want to do. Why?
Because we're not being honest about what it actually,
what is involved in selecting against people.
So you brought up the issue of interests. So like the Google memo,
the James Demora issue, right. For Exit, a great example publicly. Okay.
But my wife went on Dave Ruben show and she, you know, sh look,
this is a woman who brought a techniques of gage field theory into economics.
So she's, she's no slouch when it comes to analytic thinking.
She's in niche field three, similar to gauge symmetry at gauge theory. Okay.
Just call it gates theory. And she wasn't, she wasn't doing,
she wasn't doing quantum theory, but she was taking, she, she, her thesis,
um,
brought techniques of bundle theory,
like the hop vibration that we had and showed that economics without any
alteration was a mature geometric system in engaged theoretical thing.
Um,
so it didn't s we collaborated on on showing that,
uh, you can't accommodate changing preferences, uh,
in economics without gauge theory.
So that was kind of pretty amazing. It was really great, great fun. The,
she, her point was,
I didn't enjoy the unpleasantness of,
um, focusing on these things because they were so abstract.
And so I wanted, you know, I was interested in people,
I was interested in making sure that our models could capture human dynamics
better. And you know, I was just really excited by the,
the collaboration we were doing, which is, you know,
she and I came from two different worlds and we found this bridge between them.
Um, so she went in, Dave Ruben and said, look, it's not about abilities.
Women are as smart as men. It's interests.
We're not interested in the same things necessarily. Right.
And that should be okay. But when she said it on Dave Ruben show,
it didn't register anywhere than date than James Demore set it and like the
world freaks, how dare you. But that's
also because he said it within the environment of Google.
He just wasn't on the podcast if he had just said.
But if he had said that same exact thing and he was an employee of Google and he
was on a podcast, even if it was a popular podcast,
I don't think it would have created as honestly as much of an issue that drew me
in. It was the fact that it's, and the fact that you can
get paid for these, you know,
these weird sort of spectrum e skills, which, you know, guilty.
That's what I care about.
I really enjoy doing isolated things in the absence of other people that have a
very technical nature to them. And you know,
my experience in general is that, uh, I, you know,
I've had female collaborators in very technical subjects.
Fewer women are interested in things that re involve isolation and technical
things removed from human interaction.
And so that statement will undoubtedly cause a flurry of activity.
And if a, if a person says it,
who is not suspected of trying to keep women out of something. Like,
my point is I want a much more equal world,
but we have a very different diagnosis as to why the world is as unequal as it
is.
And your diagnosis is that it's unequal because people have varied interests and
that, but also like something as dumb as kin work.
When can work women take care of sick relatives,
children and the elderly at a level that most men can't be bothered with.
You know, it's just like, Eh, I don't care. So you know,
you've got all of these guys hyperfocused on their career who are doing the
equivalent of jumping down a flight of stairs on a skateboard. You know,
maybe it's not healthy. And then you've got an a,
another group of people who are, it's like saying, you know,
I want to have children,
I want to stay home with the kids for a couple of years because it's really
important in terms of their development and bonding and all these things.
And I say, absolutely,
how do we create a financial product that gets you money early in your life when
you need it? And then you know, maybe you pay something out when you're like,
it's just a different diagnosis as to what the problem is.
It's not all oppression. Part of it is resources and financial products.
Part of it is interest.
Part of it is the fields being set up in a way that is biased.
I do believe in structural oppression.
I just don't believe in the level of structural oppression or the remedies for
Starks structural oppression. Like if we don't,
we are losing many of the best minds that are on female shoulders.
We've just are. There's no question about it. My mind. And rather than saying,
what do you mean by we're losing them? Well, they exit the system. We, we, they,
they, they get through the like let's say bas and stem subjects.
A lot of them enter PHD programs. Like,
let me give a very simple example from the Harvard math department from years
ago,
I think Harvard had this weird thing where it would very often allow one woman
in a year to the phd program in mathematics and that person usually felt
isolated and would often kind of leave the program and then one year a female
who is admitted deferred.
So that meant that there were two women starting the next year and they formed a
support network and they both got through and then other women came in after
them. So it was like, oh, that's interesting. We just learned something.
Right. If you, if you let women in in pairs,
maybe they're going to do better and then then maybe three will do better or
four will do better. Okay.
I'm totally up for that kind of a remediation up until we can build up enough
female experience so that women have role models.
I think it's really helpful to be able to look at a senior female researcher and
go to her and say, how did you do it? You got married, you had kids,
you had a very successful career. How did you come back? You know,
one of the things I found,
I used to be interested in this problem and I found that a lot of the women in
the 1950s were very successful in stem subjects,
had a lot of money or their husbands had stable jobs that allowed them to use
nannies and housekeeping in order to free themselves from drudgery.
Well that was an unamortized feature of the system because that's not available
to everyone. That's a, it's a feature where financial privilege, uh,
actually enabled somebody to stay in science. So, you know,
the issue isn't a question of inclusion or exclusion of groups.
It's a question of how are you so sure that everything is structural oppression.
That's, that's a really weird thing.
And if you can launch that objection cheaply, if you can just say,
I can take any group and say, why is this group have no one in a wheelchair?
Now I've got to spend 30 minutes explaining that. Right? I don't want to do it.
It's not a good enough objection. Like if we're going to make progress,
let's actually make progress that matters rather than making ourselves feel
good.
Why do you think that this social justice movement has reached such hysterical
levels over the last decade? Well, a couple things. One, I think that,
um,
certain positions became like the failing business of traditional media meant
that you couldn't actually employ people, uh,
at the same level that you could employ them before.
So a lot of people who didn't have huge opportunity costs entered journalism.
Um, what does that mean about huge opportunity for us?
Let's imagine for example,
that you're very ideological and somebody offers you a,
uh, $50,000 a year job,
which allows you to be ideological or you could take $150,000 a year job.
And ideology isn't a large part of, of, uh, the offer.
Only the ideological people are going to give up $100,000 a year for the
privilege of activism.
[inaudible] so in part when you have a failing business model,
you start select is a system of selective pressures.
It's going to start selecting for very different people.
So that's one of the things that's going on is,
is that you have very economically frustrated people because the silent
generation started a problem. The baby boomers amplified the hell out of it.
Gen X is still waiting to take its place in society and the millennials just
don't even see a path through, you know, standard careers.
Nobody's putting a, uh, a glass of scotch in their hand,
in a cigar in their mouth and saying, come with me kid.
Let me show you how it's done. Well,
isn't it also partly because the discussion is out there and the discussion is a
very attractive one.
The discussion of one of the reasons why you haven't gotten by in this world is
because of inequality and because of some sort of systemic racism or systemic
sexism or systemic homophobia or transphobia. And it becomes,
when you give people an option to find an excuse,
they gravitate towards that excuse when you create safe space, right?
And you coddle and you make, all of these pieces are in place. There's many,
many, many moving parts. Right?
And I think all these little pieces are in place where we're,
we also have these massive echo chambers because of social media.
We have these people that, you know,
they find ideologically similar human beings and they bounce off of each other.
These were all real problems.
Like I have an intersex friend who I was seeing somebody who's indeterminate
between male and female physiologically. So, okay,
let's imagine that they have some karyotype x,
y profile and that the developmental process did not produce an ambiguous
genitalia. Okay. Okay. Is that a hermaphrodite? I don't want to, okay.
Just intersect. Okay.
This is a person I think of pretty terrific and I look at all the forms that say
male, female, and I just, you know,
my heart sinks like we're not even in trans here.
We're talking about somebody whose biological card that they were dealt.
Could have been. You could have been me, right and through no,
no choices at all.
This person is being shoehorned into a paradigm which puts them in an increased
risk of suicide. And it breaks my heart and we should change it.
We should break the male female dichotomy. Absolutely.
Now I have a different feeling about trans,
but if we solve the issue of intersects, which is not pressuring,
just accepting that some tiny percentage of the population which is not
vanishingly small, just not large,
is neither unambiguously male and female in terms of genotype, phenotype,
concordance.
We will do most of the work necessary to take care of our trans folks who are
suffering. Right now.
Trans is a much more rich world because there are a million different issues
taking place in trans and they're all conflated, you know,
part of it because of developmental biology part of it, because, um,
gender really in some sense is socially constructed in a way that like when
people say mathematics is socially constructed, I have to reject it. Um,
you know, I, and I give example of like
kilts and loonies, uh,
from Scotland in India are skirts but they're not female in those places.
So you have to learn about male and female relative to the codification in your
society and the issues of what are our,
what are our obligations to recognize, hey, this is really a,
a female mind and a male body versus this is a regular mind and irregular body,
but needs instruction. All of these things are conflated.
And I was really hoping that we, if you know,
if we used intersects as the test case to break them, the,
the binary because the binary is an oppression.
There's no question in my mind about it.
About how is it an oppression because it, let's imagine that I,
let's say I have persistent Mullerian duct syndrome.
So I'm phenotypically on the outside mail and I go to my doctor and he says,
Hey, you've got a uterus. What? Yeah, you have a uterus.
Okay, that's an exotic situation. Um,
maybe I want to identify male, you know, because the,
the outside equipment looks male. It's a, it's a, it's a weird situation.
Maybe the idea is that we're talking to an extremely rare circumstances.
So does that really define it as being oppressive? Like go like what is for,
for a friend of mine who is in neither situation, yeah, it's oppressive.
But I mean is it a pro? Like some people are born paralyzed, right?
Some we're are born with like serious neurological diseases that don't allow
them to be motile. That's right.
Like what is it oppressive if people are just recognized,
like most people recognize as being able to walk if there was no category called
um, dis disabled. Right. Okay.
Or in a wheelchair. Okay. No category. All right. Yeah.
So you've got somebody who's,
who's got a spinal cord injury and you've have people saying, all right,
everybody walked this way. What do you mean you can't walk? Get up?
Where are you lazy? That's what it sounds like to me.
Like it's one thing to recognize that not everybody is in the standard category,
but it's another thing to hard code,
like hard code where you talking about Java forms,
the federal government gives me a form. There's a binary,
it says male or female.
Let's imagine it doesn't say other or prefer not to say. Okay, so,
so we're just talking about filling out forms, which is,
how often does that take place in your life?
Often enough that it represents oppression where you have to look to find
emotional or female emotionally, emotionally, I think this is oppression.
Oppression, yeah. I might look,
maybe isn't it done under the interests of defining people simply because for
the most part you're dealing with males and females and for the most part
they're just trying to figure out what's what for their statistics.
But you know, again, this is, this is fine.
I'm glad you're asking me these questions because usually I have to be on the
other side of this issue. And this is really where my heart is,
which is I care these people. And I know
that in every single conservative society in the world,
there are accommodations made for the failure of simple binaries to accommodate
the population. There's no society, this I,
there's no society so conservative that they've sorted the world into male and
female. You know,
the famous example of a in Iran of, uh, the ayatollah,
um, making a fatwa that said it's fine to have a gender reassignment,
right?
We have to recognize that every single population produces gender,
sexual ambiguity.
But isn't that also to get around the idea of homosexuality being aggrieved as
crime?
Cause like I believe in Iran it's illegal to have homosexual activity,
but you can have gender reassignment. So if you're a gay man,
you can choose to become a female. That's true.
But there's also a thriving gay scene in Tehran,
you know, do they have to recognize as female?
And there are all sorts of executions there.
There was a situation in India where I, you know,
I have more experience where you would say, oh,
those two people are confirmed bachelors, you know,
that they're so dedicated to their professions that there's no room for family
and they live together. Right. So like traditional societies have,
everybody accommodates homosexuality and failures of simple gender binaries.
And you know,
I always bring up the example of Turkish where Turkish doesn't hardcode the
third person singular pronoun as male or female.
It just has one pronoun for both. So
thank you for giving me the opportunity to show where my heart actually has been
this entire time,
which is I believe this is oppressive and I don't think that it presses that
many people,
but I believe that it's an important oppression that we have to realize that we
hard coded and that's what generated a lot of the feelings before we get to
trans.
You can simply say from the position of intersects that the world is a richer
place than male and female and people say, oh it's x x versus x, y. It's like,
no it isn't. It just isn't.
It for the most part is for the most part it is.
So in terms of it is it, it has been an edge case to deal with,
but that edge case is important to me. Right? Cause the edge case are,
they are human beings that are not only that, I actually,
I like people who are outside of the norms.
I think that probably a larger percentage of those people are going to be more
interesting people because they're forged in the fire.
So it's not just a case that you know, do you want to chase a cup,
a couple of edge cases.
Everybody with a really different experience is more important to me than
everyone. With the standard experience.
I think we have to kick take care of the standard case,
but I'm absolutely interested in outliers and edge cases. So
to get back to the,
to to the line of thought
important distinction and what you're saying is very important because you are
in one way,
someone could pigeonhole you from your earlier statement that you are not
interested in a lot of these different studies,
Grievance Studies, a lot of these, a gender studies,
if they in f interfere with hard science, which you are getting,
particularly with evolutionary biology, you're getting a lot of interference.
You got to right and you're not interested in that.
But that does not mean that you're an insensitive person that's uninsured and
human being. You're just not interested in the disruption of the,
that the acquiring of data and the analysis of said data.
I don't think that activism makes for good advancement.
Why do you think
problem with who's the activist and what age you're talking about and how
idealistic these people are and what, how are, how, going back to biology,
where's their mind at it? How, how formed is their mind?
How narrow is their view of what the world is or should be and their impact?
You know, what, what, what's, what's significant about [inaudible]
but my, my disagreement, just give you an idea of where my energy comes from.
Let's imagine that you actually believe that males and females are equally
intelligent. Okay. Just fishery and equivalents.
Can I say lol?
Then your, then what would you be?
You'd be fascinated as to why you don't have males and females in an
intellectually depending in equal numbers in any,
in an in a demanding occupation. So you'd start saying, Huh,
if I already assumed that males and females are equally intelligent,
I care about different categories. How much of this is about fertility?
How much of this is about kin work?
How much of about of this is about structural oppression?
How much of this is about path dependence?
You do some very careful thing in order to understand your problem and only when
you'd finally understood your problem would you say, okay,
now I have an idea of how to remediate it.
We need a financial product that transfers money from late life to early life
because this huge burden that knocks women out of the stem pipeline might be,
uh, that they have to take care of elderly parents or young kids. Bingo.
Now you, now you're working in a totally different idiom because you've,
you've actually come up with a different idea or for example, um, if,
if you make,
if you hard coat like Sean Carroll I think just had a podcast in which he said
something to the effect of, well,
on the IDW is kind of into interested in race and IQ.
I have never been interested in race and IQ.
The only time I became interested in race and IQ was when I started hearing.
There is absolutely no variation between groups and you know,
in any of a cognitive
endowment. Well certainly there is in terms of height,
the ability to radiate heat melanin can attend to the skin.
The ability to absorb sunlight.
It doesn't pass the smell test that you could be able to say that a priori,
it's just, it's not a scientific type statement.
It's something you'd have to investigate.
So in that situation, am I interested in,
in some finding that says that one group is smarter and other groups are not as
smart? Do I believe that IQ equals smartness? No,
I don't believe IQ equals smartness. Do I believe that there's no cultural bias?
I think there is cultural bias. I, you know, I've,
I'm definitely on record of saying, um,
there are ways in which groups that are said to a fair less well in terms of IQ,
uh, demonstrate actual intellectual dominance. This is some rich,
weird area I've never cared about before.
And the only reason that it becomes interesting to me, um,
is that suddenly we're,
we're making these incredible proclamations with certainty. Like,
you know, you can't say this word or this is absolutely true.
And like life doesn't work like that. There's no word in the English language.
George Carlin made this point all the time. There are no bad words.
There's bad intent. They're bad people. Well,
isn't that also the issue being a part of a group?
Say More I the IDW is too interested in race and IQ.
I'm not. I'm not. Who is, I mean I'm really not. I don't discuss that at all.
I understand, but who? Who is interest? Sam Harris has discussed it before,
but he discussed it with someone who is studying. I don't think Sam, Karen.
I think that Sam felt that he had,
Sam felt the Charles Murray had been railroaded by him by he Sam Harris,
and then as Sam came to understand what it is like to have a mob turn on you.
Sam said,
maybe I'm wrong about Charles Myrrh and then air as reclined made this really
interesting point in a really unfair way against Sam, which was basically like,
hey, you don't know what Charles Murray is. He's a hybrid.
He's not just a social scientist. He's also got an agenda. Right?
Is that accurate? I think so. I've never read Marie's work,
but I don't know enough to say either, but I believe polarizing.
I think Al Curve,
the whole idea about being able to recognize a,
the differences in gender and race and IQ,
it's like it's a very contentious subject. Both analyze.
I mean, look, I have to admit that I don't score that well on certain tests,
so I have a built in total skepticism of IQ tests,
sat test, act tests,
any kind of test because it's an unnatural examination, not intelligence.
It just isn't, what is it? It's a proxy. Like there are people who think, oh,
it's a really good proxy.
I'll never met someone who has a really high IQ though,
that I deemed to be intellectually inferior. Yeah.
But I've met people who don't have very high iqs who just blow me away. Yes.
Right. Well, there's absolutely,
there's a type of intelligence a certain people possessed particularly creative
intelligence. Yeah.
There's a creative and like there's certain people that might not score well on
sat tests, but they're capable of producing amazing stuff,
whether it's literature, comedy, whatever. Whenever it is movies,
they can make things, they can do things.
They have a genius in their ability and that requires some intelligence.
It requires some immeasurable. There's something that you can't put on a scale.
Well, this is about, you know what I said to Jordan, I said, Jordan Peterson.
I said, I don't think I have an IQ because the conceit,
we have to remember that a priori,
we would always have guessed that I t intelligence was many different things.
It was a composite of like lots of different types of intelligence.
The concede around IQ is you'd think that was true. But guess again,
there's essentially one kind of intelligence. There's one scale.
It's a surprise. Oh, that's, that's really surprising.
Tell me something of the various forms of intelligence is one of the things that
you call intelligence processing. Yes. Yes. Processing, very important.
Okay. I don't score well on processing. In fact,
I don't think anyone in my family has ever scored well On.
What do you mean by processing? I don't know. Some kind of, um,
mechanical process of how quickly and flawlessly you can encode information,
play with it and get it out. You know, like if you're a dyslexic, well,
let's take spelling. Lots of people on Twitter say,
ha ha you misspelled here. Uh,
in fact it's h e Ar in the case that you meant,
it really just shows me something about your intelligence that you can't keep
track of spelling. Okay. That's your level of thought.
Do you happen to know how many brilliant people can't, can't spell, can't write.
Well also you're not even thinking,
you're just trying to get the word out and you miss step. Yeah.
But like my mind, you know,
at some point I got sent home I think because I was asked to draw a chicken in
school and I put two wings and four feet on it. I'm so non observant. My, my,
my handwriting might at home. Yeah. Something like this. They sent you home.
I was like abberant or you know,
I was making fun of the teacher cause it was for like a check, you know,
famously Mrs Buckero in first grade sent me out of the class because I said that
a spider wasn't an insect because it had eight legs and that she sent you out of
the class. Yeah, because I was, well you're correct.
In that case I was in the case of a chicken, I wasn't,
but well maybe he saw some weird fucking Chernobyl chicken. So yeah, man.
Chernobyl chicken, chicken Kiev. That's good. That's comedy goal.
My point,
my point being that if you don't have a high confidence in net normal metrics,
the race and IQ discussion doesn't land like so to get back to Charles Martin.
So Charles Murray
is it book, it's hard to say.
He wrote the bell curve, right?
A was either dismissed as being racist or applauded by people who you would call
white nationalists who tried out his ideas as proof,
as measurable proof that certain races are superior and you know,
we could discuss the online people who trot those out all the time and they use
it to form these weird groups of people that love to hear that. Right.
And that smacks of racist. So this is the issue,
which is you have a situation in which he appeared to heavy political
orientation,
which is that he didn't want money spent in certain ways and he wanted it spent
in others. There.
There was an in political interpretation of why he wanted that,
which was maybe he's a closet racist.
Then there was facts that will tend to empower people who are actually racist.
All right, but let me pause you there. Sure.
But then there's the actual data right now in examining the actual data,
if you just look at the actual data is,
is it racist to look at the,
the real numbers I give you say Nigerians in particular who are incredibly
industrious and some of the more, um,
successful immigrant groups that come over to America also happened to be black.
If you wanted to look at Nigerians in terms of like, if you wanted to, if you,
if you, if all, if you, if you wanted to look at them particularly as a group,
be very difficult to be racist. You'd have to say, wow, this is,
these are superior. Lot of superior intellects come from Nigeria.
They also tried out the Asian one, right? That ate like this.
One of the weird things that people like to show that they're not racist.
Like look at shows. Asians are of a superior IQ. Aye. Aye.
Aye Puzzle on that one. That one's puzzling.
Say More because I think with certain people,
with certain males, let's just go with males.
They look at African Americans and they see superiority in in certain ways,
they see superiority athletically, artistically, musically.
If you look at the contributions of African Americans culturally across the
board in terms of like the real, the, the Jimmy Hendrix, the Beatles,
Davis seed of thought and creativity analytic,
but not just that. Also athletically, like the,
the fucking outliers are just so many. There's so many. Michael Jordan's,
Mike Tyson, sugar ray Leonard's,
there's so many African American outliers who are just extraordinary in terms of
their accomplishments, but not that many Asian Americans in that regard.
So it's almost like they'll concede like they're not doing the things that make
me jealous. Do you see what I'm saying? They're not,
they're not creating this insane music, although there are few. Right.
But overall they're not creating these insane athletic accomplishments that
these white Americans can't keep up with. Right. So we'll say, but look,
they're superior intellectually, so I can't be racist.
I am pointing out that these Asians who I'm not jealous of because they don't do
the things that I wish that I could do.
But then when it comes to the African Americans,
you're there pointing out all the things of the African Americans can do that
they can't do,
but they're saying all but they're intellectually inferior by this is proven.
I'm not racist. I don't want this to be true. But it seems to be true. I see.
You see what I'm saying? It's like a way of,
it's a way of suppressing accomplishment, right?
While like almost mitigating the impact of the, the,
the jealousy that they feel. So if you think about, for example, first,
does that make sense?
I th I think so. Um, first of all, I just,
I hate this topic.
Yeah, me too. It's a weird topic cause it's a weird topic.
It feels greasy even touching it.
But now we have to write like this. I feel like
my wrong view of it is if you'd never brought this thing up,
we would never have had to deal with it.
And I no longer believe that's true because we have so much inadvertent data,
right? Like I don't want, um, the data on chess.
We have an idea of how many grandmasters there are in which groups like male,
female, Asian, black, you know, various portions of Europe.
I don't know what that data means,
but I can't stop the data because it's going to be generated even if nobody
comes up with a standardized test because it's a game and it's scored and it has
something to do with intellectual abilities, right? On the other hand,
I mean, I'm a competitive guy and I, I, um, you do comedy, I do some,
some amount of music. Uh,
I can guarantee you that both of us have had our ass kicked at some point by
African Americans who excel in both of these areas. And I don't mean, um,
you know, all God's children got rid of them. I mean, getting out funk, uh,
in a competitive situation, um, you know,
looking over somebody's shoulder on the keyboard and they're thinking so quickly
and in so many dimensions, I can't even imagine what the hell is going on.
Right? So therefore I never had a lot of fear about it because I, you know,
I'm in close proximity with somebody who's just kicking my ass and um,
therefore I thought I could leave these topics alone.
I would never have to deal with it. The way in which that they come up,
you know, in a way that is really unpleasant is this new thing,
which is that all imbalances are all structural oppression. Right.
And which doesn't allow for tradeoffs between groups like fins.
Fins are good at some things. They're not good at others.
Nobody believes in like anti finished prejudice.
So we don't think about it all right. It's just not a,
it's not a big issue for us now. Finnish humor,
how many finished comedians are there have no idea. Right.
Well how many do you run into at the comedy store? That's a bet
bad example because you're dealing with America,
America in American comedy and also you're also dealing with the highest level
of the game. It's like, you know, the, the comedy store is essentially like the,
it's like the Harvard research labs of standup comedy. Yeah.
But
nobody's worried about anti finish behavior.
We're worried that we're prejudiced against certain groups.
We're worried that we're prejudiced against Jews.
We're worried of that we're prejudice against Mexicans against blacks.
We have a pretty clean idea of what bigotry we really still need to worry about.
Right. And we feel guilty about it.
And that's why you say it has this kind of lubricious quality to that.
What are you really up to over there? Well, why are you looking at that Dataset?
Right? And what my comment is is I don't know how to stop this thing.
I'm not excited about it. I'm not interested in it.
I definitely think that we have to actually think about the social implications
of all of these things. But if your,
if your ideas that we're going to stop this at the level of data and analysis,
I can't afford that. I just can't afford that.
We need to have somebody who is able, like for example, microcephaly.
You've got people with smaller heads than the rest of us.
Maybe because of the Zika virus. Well, is it,
is it unethical to study what the cognitive impairment due to Microcephaly is?
Right? I don't know.
I Dunno what to do,
but I know that I want to have a very thoughtful conversation about how can it
be,
how can it be unethical to study the cognitive impairment of someone who should
affect affected by a disease? And that could possibly help fund research,
help fund preventative measures. Why would there's a correlation with,
with smaller heads and cognitive impairment, you know,
and like what does somebody like, let's take mosaic down syndrome.
Mosaic Down Syndrome doesn't have the same profile as regular downs syndrome.
You get much higher functioning people, right? I mean,
ultimately we're all souls and we have to figure it dignity and we have to
figure out some system by which we can live with this increased level of
knowledge, but does examining impairment, right?
Does that really mean that it's a prejudiced?
Like what about an examining impairment from people who've been injured?
Should we avoid doing that because we don't want to be ablest.
Um,
do you see what I'm saying? Not Quite, because we're talking about reality,
right? We're talking about issues. If you're,
if you're examining someone who contracted the Zika virus and it led to them
developing a smaller head, which is one of the horrible side effects of that,
is examining that in some way, some sort of prejudice.
It should we avoid examining their cognitive. If we avoid examining it,
we might do some damage.
If we examine it and publish the findings, we might do da do da.
I mean [inaudible] might do damage to the people that are in fact look or
afflict if we don't begin with an idea that ultimately the issue is compassion
for ourselves and others and that a lot of our genetics and our,
his history dis predisposes us to bad behavior now that we're living with each
other. Like we have to start, I mean as hippy dippy as a salad,
you have to start from a place of love and decency. I care. I certainly agree,
but I think that we should avoid reality. This is the thing, right? Yeah.
So now I have this other thing which is reality is compassionate in and of
itself.
Remember when HIV was an equal opportunity disease and it just started in the
gay community and it's gonna jump the fire road and it's going to be as much a
heterosexual problem as it was a homosexual problem that turned out not to be
true.
It was an ideological statement that didn't look at the differences between
different kinds of epithelium and different sexual practices between gays and
straights. It was a, it was a,
an activist position that started to compete with a epidemiological position or
a biological position.
And so historically what we did is we had private expert communication.
Um, and it's not always clear that you can trust your experts.
It's not always clear that you should start with the data.
What if the data says terrible things,
like maybe the data on people with Microcephaly, um,
says something and you have got a person who's going to be judged by the size of
their head, which is visibly off from the rest of their body. You know, we,
we haven't taken up the challenge of our time, which is okay,
we got a lot more information than we wanted and we have a lot more ability to
analyze it and we know something about ourselves.
We know that we have got bigotry as part of our,
our makeup and we know that, um,
we're not really good at certain ways of integrating information and not,
you know,
becoming triumphalist and jerkish about it and taking victory lapses if it's a
competition like my groups better than your group. Right?
So that's where we're stuck.
Now I want to be struggling with other people are saying, look,
I don't know what the answers are. I don't think, you know,
as I brought up before,
I don't think East Africans are cheating in the Boston marathon because they've
come to dominate it. Just because you know,
suddenly you had a diverse group of people replaced by a very tiny group from
Ethiopia and Kenya. We are,
we are behaving as you would expect when compassionate people who recognize that
they have been bigoted and structurally oppressive
encountered data that they can't handle,
which the science is giving us more data than we ever wanted on these things.
And we're not answering the challenge of our time. And that's what my issue is,
social justices. It's not about,
I don't want a better planet or more inclusive.
It's like stop crowding out the really difficult,
interesting,
openhearted and hardheaded conversation with this dime store nonsense about
simple answers and simple,
simple truths because those aren't true and it's not going to work in the
longterm. I mean,
I guess that's maybe the idea is we're competing with social justice for the
rights to try to come up with a better, more equitable future.
And the complaint about it isn't, you guys are trying to come up with a better,
more equitable future.
It's what if you're gonna make the same mistake when we said, well,
the heterosexuals are as much at risk as the homosexual. Well, that wasn't true.
We needed to devote resources to our homosexual community and we did need to get
the heterosexual community interested and we had a problem and we needed to
think about, you know, very thoughtfully,
we've got an epidemic that's killing people.
I think when we're talking about this,
I think everything you're saying resonates and everything you're saying makes
sense. Uh, and I think when we're talking about compassionate,
compassionate human beings looking out for each other, right?
And that this should be something that we, all,
this is like one of the, one of our primary concerns whenever we address any,
any issue, right? I think our problem in this country, there's as many problems,
but one of our problems is the loudest voices on the fringes.
And this is one of the things that I wanted to discuss with you is what's going
on in Portland.
And I think what's going on in Portland is the loudest voices on the fringes
that the people on the right and on the far right and whether they are,
recognizes, is recognizing as emblematic of the left.
They think it defines the left. And I don't think it does.
And I think it is, it's a symptom of,
it's a symptom of, first of all, terrible government of, of,
of someone who's allowing this to flourish inside the,
the mayor of Portland who seems to be supporting this in some sort of a weird
way, weird way. And,
and ideologically believes that Antifa just because of a name stands for
antifascist. If you had no name,
which you would have as a bunch of hood wearing mask,
wearing violent thugs who are beating people who disagree with them because
that's what we saw with that. Andy, how do you say his name go? Is it,
I think it's Indian? No, no. And it's NGO, right?
I treated the G is silent until somebody, correct. I think you're right. Um,
what you saw from that video that anyone could support that of with a person
who's just talking, they, I mean, he, if what I've seen of him,
what they have tried to describe, that he supports neo-nazis,
that he supports the proud boy. I haven't seen none of this.
I've seen no evidence of this,
but I've seen the narrative trotted out over and over again as a justification
for violence against him.
When the supports bullying in the worst possible form,
ganging up on someone, punching them, hitting them with sticks, crow bars,
all this crazy shit thinking that it's okay to throw milkshakes at people
thinking that this is fine. This is nothing. If you see what I think,
this is a horrible precedent to set and it's a terrible,
it's, it's a terrible move. If you're playing a game,
it's a terrible foe first move because things only escalate.
They don't deescalate. No one says, wow, you beat the shit out of Andy. No,
this is a mystery, right? Like what the Hell is going on? Right?
What the hell is,
could you allowing people to wear masks and carry backpacks with weapons and
there's a natural human inclination when someone gets hit to jump in and hit
them too. So if you see it all the time,
watch worldstar go to Worldstar hip hop.com and watch someone gets hit.
A bunch of people just jump in and hit him.
It happens at truck stops and fucking high schools. It happens.
People get brain damage, people touching each other all the time.
People permanent injury. When you're seeing in Portland,
there was one of them where an old guy got hit in the head with a fucking
crowbar, right?
Some mass kid because the old guy apparently disagreed or they all disagree on
things they don't.
Someone's decided guesses that the old guy is not exactly as portrayed.
I believe that the old guy may have been there with a telescoping baton.
Oh, so he was hitting people. Let's take this. I think this is so worthwhile,
but like let's do it right, because I think this is so mysterious.
What the help or people doing supporting Andy know being beaten up on video,
so let's stay. Stay with him because that's the best,
clearest example of someone who's a tiny little gay man. He's tiny.
I mean he represents so many different maligned populations. Right?
He's pretty intersectional. Yes. He's Asian. He's an immigrant.
He's an immigrant. He's gay. I is he a Republican.
I thought he was left of center. I was told that he was a conservative, well,
I've been told I'm a fucking alt-right guy, so it's very confusing. All right.
He's also a diminutive in physical form as he's not dead,
he's not threatening physically. Right. And uh,
they've chosen this guy as an example and one of the more disturbing things for
how many people saw the video and we're justifying it saying things like,
get another hobby. These engines are the antifascist will not stand for,
you know, your, your, your bigotry and your hate.
Like what are you talking about? You think it's okay to punch this guy?
Like the fact that you guys all piled on and punched him. And this is so,
I've been thinking a lot about it. I have a model. I'm,
I'm happy to hear yours because there is a mystery.
Can we both agree to be at the beginning that you would imagine that that video
would have shocked people and to find so many people sort of excusing it is
really shocking. Well, it's given that he's also interested,
clearly intersectional. Yeah. You wouldn't predict this from first principles,
right? No, you wouldn't do, we looked it on paper. You definitely wouldn't.
Especially if if you allowed him to self identify as leftist center.
Okay, so here's how the, I think the model goes. Okay.
And unless you want to give yours first. No, go ahead. Alright.
Okay.
The first thing that we have to understand is that there's a division,
I want to lay this out super carefully.
The first division is between the,
what you're calling the loudest voices,
and I'm going to call the most courageous. Oh,
I don't want to call courageous. The most willing to accept loss.
The voices most willing to accept loss.
Most of the left does not want to be dragged to the extreme left.
And so you hear this thing about why are you focusing on a fringe?
And the answer is because the fringe is running the show, in my opinion.
What do you mean by willing to accept loss?
Okay.
If you go into an antifa versus proud boys melee,
you're willing, you accept that you may get clocked with a bike lock.
I don't think that's correct, Tom. I don't think that's correct.
I think you're dealing with people that have no concept of real violence,
no experience of real violence. We've seen it. If you've seen it, yes,
they're there. It's fucking cosplay. It's cosplay alert.
Have you seen the image of the guy who's a suspect?
It looks like he's never worked out a day in his fucking life.
Looks like he's never been outside,
and I think these people are playing a fucking game. We've agreed on it, yes.
Okay, but you are willing,
so you're think you're going to get into a Wiley coyote versus the road runner
kind of a thing where both of them always survive to the next car.
Do you have no idea what they're doing if they ever,
have you ever seen a fight between people that have no idea how to fight? Yes.
Yeah. Okay. We all have. I've been one of those. Okay.
That stuns me as a martial arts expert.
It stuns me that people are willing to participate in that.
It's like me not knowing how to get in a motorcycle and getting in a race.
I don't. I don't know how anyone's willing to do that,
but they're willing to do that and they're willing to do that because they're
delusional and they're supported in their delusion or perspective by the giant
numbers of them they all get to get and then then the wear masks,
which further emphasizes this illusion that they're a joke game. You look,
assume that you are not even in a physical situation,
you're willing to be very loud on social media about very simplistic
perspectives. Yes,
and you're willing to become a pariah at some level because are you though?
I think mostly your support. I need far more support.
I'm not necessarily,
you are going to trigger so many times on this explanation that I probably just
need a little place in the table to start building this up and then you can tear
it to the hell. Okay. Okay. The first belief is,
is that the belief that I have is that the fringes are much more running the
show than the people who claim that this is a small number of people believe
that the fringes are scary, fringes are willing to go places. The rest of us,
I agree with you
on both sides left and right, left and right.
So I spend a lot of time focused on the fringes because the fringes have become
terrifying and the middle has become cowardly.
And the whole principle of about the whole idea,
I believe thing was about creating a non cowardly
core that could actually potentially hold the center.
Um, because people are actually fairly courageous. Like you would have to say,
my brother is fairly courageous. Ben Shapiro, Andy, no, Sam Harris.
These are people who have stood up to death threats. You know, I,
I have a guy who was threatening me every day of my life. Uh, you know,
coming through the Internet and my family,
you have to have some courage in order to be part of this thing.
And that's more part of my irritation when people come after it.
So there is a cowardly center and a very terrifying fringe and the fringe is
going around the whole thing right, left and right.
The next thing is that people are secretly,
weirdly sympathetic, but they're violent.
The violent fringe to their extreme rather than making common cause across the
center. So for example,
you imagine that you run a laundromat and you're being visited by a member of
organized crime every week and he comes into your laundromat and he kind of
plays with your stuff and he says,
it'd be shame if anything happened to your business and he shakes you down.
Start Saying, Oh, you know, I noticed that you have a daughter.
I would love to date her. Perhaps. Perhaps we'll go out some time,
you hate this guy. And then some sort of violent village,
vigilante element that's operating extra judicially after you've gone to the
police over and over again breaks this guy's kneecaps.
Right?
You're weirdly sympathetic with the vigilante because you're being terrified by
a group that is not being taken care of.
I think that this is in part why some elements of the left that are should be
more responsible, that have institutional positions,
that have platforms that they can broadcast are weirdly sympathetic to Antifa
and why country club Republicans are weirdly sympathetic to some of these far
right groups is that they view them as this is the dangerous group that's kind
of taken care of the problem that I can't stand up to.
So you've got this bizarre,
cowardly sympathy from the center who won't actually stand up and say,
I have more in common with a country club Republican. Like in my case,
I view myself as a progressive or at least a liberal.
I have more in common with a country club Republican than somebody who's got a
bike lock who's looking for trouble in a street demonstration trying to smash up
a Starbucks. Right.
I don't want the help from my left.
Now the,
the group that wants to play this out using these sort of proxy groups to handle
the problems. It's saying, look,
we're going to,
we're going to sound an air horn before one of these things so that all
reasonable people can get the hell out of the way. And if you don't respond,
then you're collateral damage and that's on you. That's how they see this.
I think that's fair. So in other words,
I think Andy No is the guy who doesn't listen to the air horn.
Bret Weinstein doesn't listen to the Air Horn, Jordan, Jordan Peterson,
Sam Harris, don't listen to the air horn. Yeah.
I think that's very accurate in your description of these fringe people doing
the work of the people that are more reasonable but are happy to have these bad
people do do their work to fight this battle for them because they think that
ultimately it's for good. Yeah.
I need my organized crime group to get rid of your organized. Yes. Right. Yeah.
And so the idea is that the law and order people are like,
I really don't want anybody's organized crime group and I'm going to actually
stand up to the mob and I'm actually not going to pay you your God damn
protection money because I'm going to own a laundromat and this is the United
States of American fuck off. That's, that's the view that I represent. Yeah.
I don't want, I don't thank you Auntie, if I don't need your help. Yeah.
You know what? I actually am much more afraid of the far right.
And the reason I concentrate my negative energy on the far left is what are you
trying to do? You're trying to get the genie out of the bottle on the far right.
That is the danger. Yeah. You want to see more Tiki torches.
It's not Tiki torches too. You need to worry about,
it's armed people who come and they know that I'm bringing bike [inaudible].
We're pushing ordinary human beings to the extremes. Yeah. Right.
And the thing that I get is,
is that like I believe that the Republican Party in our desk,
I never get a chance to say this stuff.
I have never gotten along with the Republican Party. I just don't like it.
I view it as the thing that wants to exclude me from the country clubs.
I have an older model.
They're the group that wanted to put in condo developments in Yosemite valley
because they couldn't figure out why we would want to preserve the national
parks. They were the ones that laughed about the clubbing, the baby seals.
Ha ha ha. I just always had this attitude, fuck these people, right?
This is mine. This is my emotional cadence.
And we always had this thing where the Democrats were this,
we had most of the smart people.
And so in a tiny fraction of time,
we have seen this giant evaporation of intelligence, uh, if not
actually through a lack of courage.
The people who represent responsible left wing thinking,
who believe in structural oppression but don't believe in the extent claimed,
you know, who want to keep making progress,
who want to make sure that traditionally marginalized groups are taken care of,
that we take our responsibilities but not our guilt as the reason for trying to
make a better world. I'm not paying reparations for slavery.
I mean, my family came over here and like what the 19 teens or twenties be,
you know,
we came from pogroms is anybody can be paying Jews for the pogroms that,
you know, how am I going to get getting Ukrainian reparations?
Let's not be ridiculous. Why do we want civil war? Do we just want to open up,
tear off every bandaid for the purpose of, uh, you know,
trying to make everybody, um,
as uncomfortable in their skin as possible.
What we have is a situation in which we don't have courageous people willing to
fight for what works.
We have a tiny number of people who are animated by this.
The reason I'm animated by this is that I'm trying to keep the pipeline open for
science. It's really what happened to my brother, um,
before it ever happened to him.
My brother and I were in this discussion about what are we going to do to make
sure that there's always a place to do biology, to do mathematics,
to be able to way, um, you know,
competing claims.
And when you start politicizing everything and you choose activism over-thought
and reason and civility and commity,
you can sign yourself to becoming, uh, a less great nation and uh,
you're no longer able to lead.
You can't build a world on angry activism that's trying to go back to a
Lillywhite nation that will never happen and you can't enforce like equality of
outcome. We don't even want that.
People who work their ass off deserved some of the pleasures of working your ass
off. And I don't always want to work my ass off. And I, you know,
Jackie Chan is the one,
I always look at that blooper reel at the end of every Jackie Chan film tells me
he deserves his money. I'm never going to do that to my body ever.
I don't want an equality of outcome with Jackie Chan.
If I make some little film and this guy's risks his life for every scene,
it's insane.
We need to create a world in which people are excited and animated about keeping
the pipeline of decent thought,
compassionate thought, openhearted thought,
and rigorous and unforgiving thought both on the table at all times and not
adulterating one to serve the other.
I don't want to see science abuse to oppress anybody and I don't want to see
somebody's dime store concept of Utopia infecting our ability to make sense of
the world. Those are, those are twin, you know,
twin directives. And this is, this is what I'm excited about.
We need to get the world excited about curing disease.
We need to get the world excited about cross pollination of ideas between
different groups.
We need to get the world excited about every that is sort of marginalized
contains neurons that we are not accessing.
Right? And so, you know, for example,
Asian females make up about a quarter of the world's population and very few of
the world's Nobel prizes.
We should be getting greedy about how do we get those Asian female brains into,
into our stem labs so that we can have the fruits of, of their discoveries.
People can't hear this because they've,
they've settled on very cheap versions of progress as time to get back to real
progress, not fake progress. How do we do that?
I agree with everything you just said, but how do we do that? Honestly,
um, this is my third time on perhaps the biggest podcast in, in the world.
I don't know. Maybe. Maybe that's giving you a little bit too much.
Credit's not very far off. We're doing that.
We're trying to stand up and if people respond and you know,
you've given me courage to start a podcast.
I gotta tell you I did not want to do this.
My brought my producer Jesse Michael's here.
I was a pain in the ass to this guy. I did not return his phone calls.
He tried to get me to sign contracts. I wouldn't look at them. Um,
I've started with this turnkey podcast company called cast media.
They put up with me for like eight or nine months where I dragged my heels. Uh,
I don't want to be famous. I don't want to be, well, no, I like,
I know while I'm sort of loud. Well, it's t look. So this is the crazy thing.
You want to get really nuts. Yes. It's time to leave. Time to leave. What?
This planet. Oh boy. Listen, we can leave this plant.
I got something right here. No, no, no. Take it to another planet right now.
He's joking. Federal agents. Let me,
let me give you my argument. Where are we going? Well,
we don't know that we can leave this planet. I love this planet.
I love this plan. I have a good time here. This is my favorite planet. Mine too.
I know. But here's the real reason.
We started a clock around 1953,
which is when we had the explosion at Bikini and the,
the first hydrogen bomb. And um,
when we figured out the double helix, and I call this the twin nuclei problem,
and it began in 1953, 1953, we started a clock.
It was also the height of the McCarthy era.
We do not have the wisdom to be able to fuse nuclei.
We don't have the wisdom to be able to investigate the cell.
It's too much power.
So our wisdom may have increased slightly. Maybe it didn't.
I don't know that our power is now godly.
So our biological intelligence,
what our minds are capable of has not it,
it's been surpassed by our intellectual achievements in terms of our,
our, our technological innovations, these things which while complicated,
um,
succumb to our intellects, right? Right.
Like they're much simpler than we ever imagined.
To be able to create something that normally happens in the sun on an island in
the Pacific, or to be able to rewrite a cell the way Craig venter did,
you know, synthetic biology,
we are now gods, but for the wisdom,
and there's a great quote, we are now God's,
but for the wisdom should be like meme pictures can picture you right now.
God, let's keep to the ones right now. I know. Let's not focus.
Okay. Sorry. Okay.
So that started this clock and the world's most serious human beings should be
working on the twin nuclei problem.
What do we do with new godlike powers given our history of conflict,
our history of envy, our history of madness, right?
Because we succumb regularly. We are, you know,
I was born 20 years after the end of World War II and we all know what really
happened there. I mean, we're nuts.
We're absolutely not capable of this level of responsibility.
And so the question that we have is,
do we believe that we have a longterm solution in terms of increasing our
wisdom? We should definitely try it.
Everybody believes that should work on that problem. But,
um, if we don't think that we have the wisdom to live like this,
we don't know how much time we have left, but it's probably not hundreds.
It's probably maybe a few hundred years tops because sooner or later you're
going to have Putin like Trump, like people. I mean,
I'm sorry. I would have a very deep antipathy towards Donald Trump. Um,
he's not temperamentally fit to have the secrets of theoretical physics at his
fingertips.
It just isn't and it's imperative to me that he not be elected in 2020 and that
the Democratic Party wake up and get rid of its crazy fringe so that we can buy
some time and it's nice if Elon thinks we can go to Mars,
maybe that will allow a small number of us to diversify in case we do something
really dumbed at the planet.
But if human beings are to continue and we are to continue evolving,
we need to spread out and there are three rocks that are inhabitable.
There's the earth,
there's the moon and there's Mars and the moon has nothing in there.
Mars is pretty uninteresting to be in blunt.
I know that it's beautiful that we send back these pictures and we've got this
one gorgeous planet that we are clearly not smart enough to Stuart.
We're still having idiotic climate change debates.
I mean even if even if climate science is somewhat junk of vide,
we should still be taking climate super seriously because we don't know what
we're doing.
It's such a complicated nonlinear system and we're not even capable of focusing,
you know, like two seconds later I'll be watching the Kardashians for sure.
So what is the answer? Well, in my opinion,
we got to increase the number of possible places we can go beyond three
to say nothing of space stations because that's not realistic. Now,
none of these things make sense.
So the first place that you have to get to is we're really deeply screwed and
not because of apocalyptic cult like reasons just because of science,
just because of 1953.
So the only opportunity is if we can break the Einsteinian speed limit so far as
I know, or we can upload into silicon or we can reboot from tardigrades.
Like none of these answers are good.
So
what I've been toying with since I was 19 was
what is the theory beyond Einstein?
And that's the thing that I've been most uncomfortable talking about. Um,
although I've been talking about it more,
I gave these lectures in 2013 and in May of 2013 in Oxford and I was appalled by
the way in which the world's physics community responded. I mean,
I was very scared. I'm not a physicist. Um,
know I don't claim to be,
but I felt like I tried to present what I hoped was a path forward given that
the field was completely stalled out. And this is it.
Physics and biology led us into the valley of death
and it's now time to try to get out and people go ahead.
No, please.
So what is my responsibility in terms of the portal?
Um,
what I'm going to try to do with this podcast is gained the courage to share
whatever ideas I've had, um,
about breaking the speed limit
in the form of,
I don't think I have the wisdom to figure out what it means,
but at least I have a hope of trying to write the fundamental rules to figure
out our source code. And that was that, that was the plan,
which is what is this place? What is the source code for reality?
Now, what was the response?
Did the physics to the physicists from the physicist that you found Pauling?
Well, there were two articles that appeared in the Guardian,
a newspaper or a website that, um,
talked breathlessly about what I had done or what I might've done to call
attention to the lectures that I was giving.
So these were the special ceremony lectures by Richard Dawkins successor,
Marcus de Sautoy,
who is a colleague of mine from way back who found me in New York City,
I think in 2011, 2012 or something like that. Working on
this theory, I called geometric unity
and I was very uncomfortable.
I hadn't really told anybody that I was working on this theory for all these
years because it's a crazy, you know,
there's certain stories that you find in theoretical physics,
which is kind of the precursor to madness where you know,
somebody thinks that they've solved, uh,
some big problem and they're working in secret, you know,
the sort of what happened with Andrew Weil's and Fermat's last theorem,
which was a really interesting story because his first proof of Fermat's last
theorem I think was unfixable.
So he announced a proof that he had solved like this most famous problem in
mathematics and he didn't have it proof.
And then bizarrely he was under such pressure that he found another proof and
actually pulled it off. So it's like, you know, hats off to him.
It's one of the crazy story,
but he was working in secret for seven years and nobody knew what he was doing.
So sometimes these stories work out.
But he was a professor at Princeton and very highly regarded and he had sort of
husband had seven years worth of work to pretend that he was releasing papers
when he was actually secretly doing this thing that would have made him a mad
man in some sense.
And so this is what I was trying to do is I was not able to work on these issues
, uh, in the string theory community because the strength theory community was
possessed of this belief that they had found the answer back in the 80s in 1984
they had what they thought was a revolution.
And the math community doesn't think in these terms.
Like both of these are very conservative communities historically and very
focused on following the leadership of the top people unless there's a
revolution.
And so I started working on a different idea to unify the two branches of
physics that appear to be incompatible.
That was different than the string theory idea in different than the loop
quantum gravity idea or any of the hazard of then your main motivation was to do
this, to try to figure out a more advanced version of space travel. Well,
it wasn't space travel. It was we need the source code like it's,
it might be safer to go further once you've unlocked,
once you've unlocked nuclear fusion,
you're pretty much just as screwed as you need to be.
So then the issue is, okay, we know that we're pretty,
I'm pretty sure that Einstein's theory is not final because you get these
singularities, which I don't associate with ultimate equations.
So the black hole singularity called the Schwartz chills singularity or the
initial singularity that we associate with the big bang, um,
and like the Friedman Robertson Walker space times are signs to me that these
equations are incomplete.
But the big problem with Einstein is that Einstein's work was so fundamental
that it's like you can't get in under the ground floor of Einstein.
You begin a physics seminar and you're already immediately in his world,
you say, let x be a space time manifold. Boom, you're already in in relativity.
So it's almost impossible to figure out a way to get in at a deeper level of
physics than Einstein's theory.
And we know that we have to recover Einstein's theory because that's been proven
, uh, you know, to work in all sorts of situations.
And the same thing with quantum field theory, which is why I talked about,
you know, the anomalous magnetic moment of the electron.
So my idea was that only since the 1970s have we known that particle theory was
based on geometry. We knew that Einstein's theory,
I thought you used geometry to develop his theory.
It was the language of relativity called Romani and geometry.
But many years later,
we found out that bores sort of quantum and plunks quantum,
and Einstein's upon them as well, was based on a different geometry of this guy.
Charles Eris man was an Alsatian geometer, uh, who'd worked with carton.
And that geometry was figured out at Stony Brook in New York by Jim Simons,
who became the world's greatest hedge fund manager and CNN Yang who was arguably
number one or number two greatest living theoretical physicist.
He's now in his nineties.
And they figured out that the secret language of particle theory was also
geometry, but a different geometry.
And so geometric unity is simply the idea that it's not a fight between Einstein
and Bohr. It's the two parents
remonde on who's I work, uh,
Einstein based relativity and Charles Eris man with this gauge theoretic stuff
that we did in the time before this, uh,
which in fact empowers a particle theory.
And so when do those two geometries unify two different geometric theories.
And I've found that in general, they don't unify in a way that you want.
You don't have the ability to do Einsteinian tensor analysis where you compress
something called the Remonde curvature tensor and the gauge stuff where you do
this gauge symmetry that we were talking about because gauge symmetry ruins the
ability to compress the Einstein tensor. Nevermind what that means.
But in one or two rare circumstances,
you can actually combine the two geometries. And that's where I think we are.
And so partially what the purpose of the portal podcast is, is to use,
um, you know, I'll just sort of tear the mask off a little bit.
We've been talking about lots of interesting things about social justice,
about um, mathematics,
about wonder about psychedelics and trying to be decent human beings to each
other and to set an example.
And I think it's been partially a success and partially a failure.
But what I'm trying to do is to gain the courage to talk about what these ideas
are. And the worst comes to worst is,
is that I wasted a lot of my life on a crazy theory that turned out not to be
true. What was the response though?
Like how did the physicist react and what was, what was
disappointing about it?
So the articles in gendered a an immune reaction.
Immune. Yeah, it's an immune response. Okay, okay.
So somebody giving a lecture and now how many times have we heard before the
next Einstein, Yada, Yada, Yada, Yada. And I totally understand this.
It's a reasonable reaction. Like Sean Carroll had this reaction.
He referred to me as a backyard. Einstein and his wife Tim,
him twice today. Yeah, he's on my mind.
And his wife wrote this amazing article in scientific American called Dear
Guardian, you've been played. Now she's not a physicist,
but she has access to Sean's brain. And she writes on physics.
And then there was this whole thing where the new scientist said, okay,
this guy claimed to give this lecture in the physics department,
but he hasn't written a paper and he didn't tell the physicists.
So it was a sneak attack. Well of course that wasn't true there.
There was announcement of the talk. Um,
I stayed in England and I give the talk once more, uh,
and then it a final time a week later. And by that point,
all sorts of people from Cambridge and Oxford came to the talk cause it was a
worldwide topic of discussion. What the Hell is going on?
And I gave a two hour talk, consider that nobody,
nobody outside of theoretical physics gives talks on physics.
It's like North Korea. They don't get many visitors, right?
To the extent that they get visitors, they do get visitors from mathematics.
But in general,
mathematicians don't take an interest in the real physical world.
And to be blunt about it,
I don't think that the strength theorists are very focused on the real physical
world either. They'd been playing with toy models for you know,
nearly 40 years.
So a lot of it was playing out in the press. Um,
and the new scientist had to retract. They said no, what we wrote wasn't true.
They did publicize the talk and then there was an article,
they sent a reporter to the final talk that I gave and the reporter did not know
any physics.
So I spent the morning with this person teaching him what the Dirac equation was
like. A very fundamental thing and question came up in the talk about is your,
is your model anomaly free? And my model is,
has a property called [inaudible] [inaudible],
which is the difference between left, right?
Asymmetric models are called chiral and left, right?
Symmetric models are called a non Cairo.
So my model is non Chiral,
but the chiral nature of the universe is supposed to emerge from it.
And I was asked questions that didn't seem to make sense, which is you,
you can't have a chiral anomaly and a non chiral model. And the person,
the reporter picked up on this and didn't really get it.
So there was like a flurry of activity with a big WTF. And if you,
if you ask me, by the time I gave the second lecture,
people weren't laughing. Um, it was a serious lecture.
People heard that it was an, it was in the light.
It wasn't like somebody come up with their own language and their own, um,
you know, written in Crayon in some indecipherable thing. It was,
it was written in the normal language, but I hadn't written a paper.
And papers are very much the stock and trade of that community.
So I would say that the, the community settled on a rubric,
which is paper or it didn't happen. In other words, put up or shut up,
give us a paper. I had written something. Um,
but because my trajectory through this,
through math and physics was very unusual.
I have a very low trust of the academic community. I support them.
As you can tell, you know,
I'm extolling the virtues of science,
but I was subjected to a situation in graduate school where I had, uh,
I'm probably the only person you've ever met with a phd who was not allowed to
attend his own thesis defense. Why is that?
I don't know. What was your thesis? It was on, um,
self dual equations not being as peculiar to dimension four as was claimed.
But I had a situation in which the thesis when I had,
when I had entered Grad school was something that you would present to the
world. And by the time I was, uh,
trying to leave,
it was a closed door affair where the department would appoint the person for
you. And I was in the unusual position of not having a thesis advisor.
So there's some very fraught story. One thing you'll find is,
is that graduate school for some subclass of people becomes an extremely fraught
experience where the power of a department,
not to grant you a degree or not to help you get a job or to expel you,
um, becomes very contentious. Right? And that was the situation.
So I got into a very contentious situation that there was no explanation of why
it was so contentious. We can talk about it on another podcast, but,
um, I was in a very low trust situation with, um,
with Harvard and with the standard community.
And so when work that I had done that was rejected from my thesis,
uh, was discovered by others in 1994, um,
and revolutionized topological gauge theory,
I became very sort of Sullen and angry and withdrawn because my department knew
that I had put forward the same equations that became revolutionary in
mathematical gauge theory. Did you revisit it with them? Um,
there was a seminar where a guy named David [inaudible], uh,
who I very much admire, uh, the person who had been my advisor,
I don't want to name names, had, uh,
given a seminar saying all of gauge theory has been revolutionized.
Old Gates theory is dead. There's a new gauge theory. And
um, David caused on who I will name, uh,
said I was in the back center row.
I think I was picking my nose actually. And um, he said,
didn't we have a student who told us to look at these equations?
And suddenly the whole room turned around and looked at me.
I think this is in room five oh seven of the Harvard Science Center.
And it's just like, you know, try to imagine you're,
you're an anonymous person in a lecture and suddenly everyone is staring at you
and your fingers in your nose. And, um, that was the moment.
And I, and I think I mumbled something, um, just to get out of it.
But I was angry. I was angry that they'd taken away my agency. I wouldn't,
you know, better, better not to give me a phd better just to say, look,
we're going to go short. You screw off, you don't get a Phd.
And then if I end up doing something, screw you. You know,
that would've been a better outcome.
So instead I got a phd through a very torturous situation and I came to give up
on academics. I don't think that they're a fair system. I don't think that, uh,
it's open-minded.
I don't think that they welcome all sorts of different belief structures,
um, which are capable of producing innovations. So, you know, for my money,
I've been very vocal about this.
I've written articles and edged title work and I've said theoretical physics has
stalled and you've been claiming that you're going to ship strength,
strength theory and since 1984 will, where is it?
And it's always, you know, and years away. Now,
what was the premise of Sean Carroll's wife's article that they got played?
Well, Jamie, can you bring it up?
I had broken the rules. The rules.
You're supposed to submit a paper. The paper is supposed to be reviewed.
It's supposed to be appear in a journal.
You're not supposed to be doing this from mathematics.
You don't have training as a physicist. This is a hoax,
but it's on hogs. Well, I don't know. I mean if it is a hoax, it's on me.
Clearly not hoax. You're not hoaxing anyone. I'm not trying to,
so I don't understand [inaudible] okay.
Imagine that you're the, you're the Princeton physics department.
You probably have a corkboard on the wall called the crank, the crank board.
And every week somebody writes to you and says,
I figured out puppy perpetual emotion. Hmm. I have a laser transport device.
Right. And so everybody is concerned and frightened that their,
their time is going to be wasted right. By lunatics.
No,
I both fit the lunatic profile and don't fit the lunatic profile on the lunatic
side. I'm outside of the system. I haven't kept up,
I'm not particularly mathematically minded. I mean, in fact,
I'm sort of a B math student from high school, so it's kind of a,
I'm the only person I know with my profile with a phd in math and on the non
lunatic side. I mean, look,
you've been listening to my crazy ideas for awhile and they're all over the
world. I have lots of heterodox ideas. I don't think that I,
that they're taken as being insane. And I don't think,
this isn't saying that it's been looked at by enough people to say will until
you actually write it down very cleanly and clearly we can't fully evaluate,
but it's a, it's a gamble. And the worst thing that can happen is,
is that I have something that looks like a final theory that turns out not to
be, are you going to write it out? It's already mostly written up.
I'm in a different phase. I felt that I got rolled in an alley.
So here's, here's the big, here's the big reveal. Okay,
it's going to be a lot harder to roll me. I can roll myself,
I can screw this thing up just fine by myself.
But the opportunity to take me into a quiet corner and make something disappear
or to hand the credit to somebody else is going to be a lot harder to do.
Is that going to happen? Did you find it?
Do Your Guardian you've been played?
I love when they use like contemporary salons. So sketchy.
It's so good. So bitchy or you want to say bitchy when it's a girl?
What I wanna grow rights it. Um, I don't, I don't care.
I think, I mean, look, it's only like the future of, of a number of people you
privately asking me about the recent guardian article and accompany an op Ed by
Oxford mathematician, Marcos du Sautoy. How'd he say it?
Said to Marcus to Soto to, so toy gushing over suppose supposedly revolutionary.
You knew unified theory of physics by a man who officially left academia 20
years ago or as I've taken to calling it the Eric Weinstein's amazing new theory
that solves everything. Puzzling conundrum in theoretical physics only.
He hasn't written an actual, all these are capital letters.
That's why I'm saying it this way. The letters and actual paper yet.
So physicists can't check
all those hard mathematical details, but trust us, it's going to be awesome.
While that's super bitchy him. Wow. Yeah. I can say that.
I can say whatever the fuck I want a him with a period. First.
A couple of caveats. I've met Weinstein. He's a nice guy.
He's wicked smart. This is a stupid article because you know better.
Well, it's just the way it's written. It's just, it's a, it's catty. Yeah.
It's C for clear. Clearly. Yeah. Okay.
We could go do, she's playing enough. She's playing enforcer. Yes.
You broke the rules. Yes. We know why you broke the rules.
There's fame and fortune for you and you think that's what it is. Yeah. Well,
or you're delusional. Or what's her motivation for writing this article though?
That's what's weird. Well, she, she's a physics look, she, she comes from, um,
I think she's approached protege of Casey Cole,
the great physics writer from WHO's not a physicist in her defense. Yeah.
Do you feel that she felt this honestly and that this was problematic and in her
eyes that you were entering into this field,
that you had not written a paper and you had left academia 20 years ago and that
she was like, listen, I'm, so, this is all nonsense. Okay,
I'm going to put a stop to this nonsense and I'm going to do it with sort of
contemporary language and, and slang. I don't like the bitchiness but it's,
I understand the motivation [inaudible] look,
I think the bitchiness is to make the article more entertaining and more,
um, it's part of horrible part of her style as a writer. Okay.
Now I actually met her as she says, and I,
I had a very high and positive impression of her.
So why do you think she wrote this without discussing it? Look,
Shawn is also one of these people who's trying to enforce the rules.
He didn't have the easiest time, I think he didn't get tenure at cal tech.
He's kind of a stickler for reality.
He's on the one hand talking total nonsense about Boltzmann brains and thought
experiments, which is what I associate with desperation physics.
On the other hand, he's kind of this rigorous, um,
rationalist thinker who's an, you know, a prominent atheist.
So he's a complicated guy. He's a great explainer. Uh,
he's got his own sort of economic incentives that he's one of the very few
people who sort of a voice physics to the world and they, you know,
operate in some sense as a couple and there's a richness to this.
Like, you know, my,
my point isn't to run them down or to boost them up.
It's just people are playing at their roles.
Whenever anyone has a sentence that consists of one word and that word is a ham.
Yeah, it's, I did not enjoy that article by him. Well, but look,
yeah, but she's trying to throw me a bone. He's wicked smart. He's a nice guy,
but he's, but he's delusional. He's delusional.
And to the extent that I've been delusional before, I'm about the
only person in the U S who's against high skilled immigration because people
think, why should we keep out the best in the brightest?
And it's complicated story. Before the financial crisis,
I was saying mortgage backed securities may blow up the world. People are like,
are you kidding? It's the great moderation. We've banished volatility.
People have a chance to know me now. They know that I can get way out there.
I said this at the beginning. I get way out there. Yeah, okay.
I think Elon Munns Musk is totally wrong about going to Mars.
Mars is not going to save us and maybe going to the stars isn't going to save us
. Maybe the AI will follow us there, Yada Yada Yada,
but I'm not going to take this lying down.
We're in a desperate situation and if you're not trying, here's, here's the,
here's the clear thing.
We know what nuclear weapons look like in the fusion here.
If we are trying to get off this planet before people are unleashing gene drives
and you know,
weaponized anthrax and who knows what the hell people are going to get up to as
the power of biology and the power of physics keeps going in the power of
information.
All right.
At least I'm trying. I think I'm doing a damn sight better than trying,
but assume that I failed completely.
How crazy is it that we're not trying to take army arms against our New Sea of
troubles? It's time to rush the cockpit.
We've got to get Trump out of office.
We've got to restore sanity door sensemaking we need newspapers.
We need fact checkers.
We did what is particularly problematic about Trump being an office.
That man has nuclear capabilities and I have zero confidence in his decision
making and people imagine that I'm a Trump supporter after I've called him an
existential risk, you know, and my,
my boss and good friend Peter Teal was a supporter of Trump in the last
election. I'm taking a huge risk in how much I love this guy,
Peter Teal and how much he loves me. Uh,
because I'm putting the employer employee relationship at risk. When people say,
okay, you're just a Peter Teal tool, well,
nobody's going to take that kind of risk unless they have real faith in their
friend. And I work for a friend.
I mean a real friend person who doesn't cut and run when trouble starts.
And I totally disagree with Peter. Uh,
I have come to understand that Trump,
I thought people would understand the Trump danger and that the democratic party
would reevaluate their situation, but they didn't.
They tripled and quadrupled down. And that is alarming.
And so that's something I very much got wrong about Trump is that even Trump
wasn't enough of a message to let people know.
But Trump cannot have the nuclear codes. Um,
because he's not as skilled or regular enough player.
He's going to accomplish a lot. One of the things I said before the election is,
is he might be the best and worst of presidents.
He might get us a new North Korea deal because they're going to look at him and
say, this guy is nuts. Who knows what he would do.
But we, we,
the technical community created this problem and we're abdicating our
responsibility by worrying about our egos, by worrying about our reputations.
I am abdicating,
I should've turned this theory over to the theoretical physics community years
ago.
Even if they screwed me over and I'm too petty and egotistical to want to give
up on it, I've watched them take credit for things that weren't, you know,
an assigned credit. I don't like the way they work. I've,
I've the theoretical physics community is our most important community in the
world and it is also a very unpleasant community and we need to fund them and we
need to let them play. They're dangerous boys for the most part.
There are women, but in general, they're very unpleasant men. Um,
they have been somewhat cowed.
They're not the same cowboys they used to be because they'd been failing for 40
years. I should be sharing stuff. I should be writing things down.
I have not had the courage to do it.
And if I really have the courage of my convictions,
I should share this and see what happens. But one thing is,
I don't know if it could be weaponized. Assume it's right. You know, I have it.
This decision tree. Assume it's wrong. I've got egg on my face. It's okay.
I'll be okay. I worry much more about if it's right.
The two things that can go wrong, if it's right,
is one that could be weaponized before it becomes useful.
And two is that there's no solution than it may be.
We actually are stuck in this place. We never get to go to the stars.
We can look at exoplanets and dream, but we're stuck here until we change.
Human behavior isn't a trip to the stars.
Just a relocation of our own thoughts. We're kicking the, we're kicking butt.
We need time, man. We need time.
We have not gotten to the point where we don't even feel the danger we're in.
We are in so much danger and we haven't had almost anything happened since 1945
at the scale of World War II.
And so we've got magical thinking between our ears where we think it can't
happen here. You know,
this is the thing that makes me so fucking furious about,
I'm screwing around with Europeans and sovereignty,
which is Europe is a dangerous place.
Europe is historically a dangerous place.
It's been a place for years where college students can go and take in the sights
.
But it's a dangerous ethnic culture and Jews know this better than anyone.
And the one thing that the far left and the far right agree on is Jews and it's
not in a good way. Right?
So it is very important. We are the canaries in the coal mine.
We feel this stuff early and things are things that are coming apart.
The the physical world, the world of commerce,
the world of like structural engineering and building permits is still okay so
far.
But the intellectual world that sort of wraps that and keeps it in check is
coming unglued. And quite frankly, I don't want to go through that again.
We cannot afford another World War II cause World War II won't,
won't look like World War II. [inaudible] three. Yeah. And I don't know,
maybe it'll look like information warfare.
Maybe it won't look like anything like a war that we've seen before. Yeah,
but you know, the problem is, Joe,
is that I've got some sort of a wildly tattooed martial artists to cross for me.
I'm some sort of guy who dropped out of academics years ago and doesn't have a
published paper in this area, and I really literally think,
and maybe it comes down to you and me,
maybe we use this podcast and some crazy ass differential geometry to at least
make a go of it to at least at the minimum,
excite somebody to think maybe it's possible to make progress. Well,
what's interesting about that is what you've said is reaching an astonishing
number of years. That's not eyes. This is why I pushed out. Look,
I've been responsible about this up until now.
This is my first really irresponsible podcast. Why is it irresponsible? No,
I don't know. Maybe it's egotistical. Maybe I shouldn't be talking about this.
I guarantee you they're going to be,
a lot of people in physics departments are going to be pissed off when this
hits. Yeah, but it's your thoughts.
There's nothing responsible about your thoughts. Well,
you have to appreciate that when you're working as hard as these guys have.
And these guys had been slogging in the salt mines for forever with no progress
in of the type. I mean, since the early seventies, it's pretty galling.
It's pretty galling to hear somebody talking like this who has the luxury of an
invite to this podcast with no vetting,
with nothing behind him other than the hope that maybe he's done something
that's interesting and I've never spoken about this. You know,
I have a recording for example, of the, the lecture that I did at Oxford,
um, which I chose not to release. You know, I just, it was so unpleasant.
Like the cattiness, the bitchiness, the nastiness, the undercutting,
the idea that this came down to ego or fame.
I guarantee you the thing that I really like least about what I'm about to do
with this podcast is fame. I think fame is a bad,
it's a bad deal. Like you, you have to deal with this.
You don't want to say what your location is, where you're going to be. You know,
people react all day long. People say, can you get me into Joe Rogan?
Can you connect me with Joe Rogan, Joe Rogan, Joe Rogan, Joe Rogan.
It's constant. I get two to three requests a week. I don't want it.
I've had a wonderful 53 years without being very well known.
And if this doesn't work out, I'll go back to being very well,
not very well known. My, my greater fears is that maybe, maybe it will work.
And then the thing that I really care about is, does it get, does it help?
Does it buy us time? Can we get off the planet? Is there anything we can do?
If we actually know the source code? You know,
John Brockman runs this thing called edge.org and every year he asked a question
to like 200 scientists.
And finally he got tired of that asking the, the annual question. So he said,
okay, 20 years is enough. The last question is, what is the final question?
And Jamie, could I ask you to bring up uh,
edge.org and my name and my answer on must've been 29,
2018.
Okay.
And it's interesting because, you know, I,
I kept putting stuff out in edge. Like for example,
I was very worried about professional wrestling, uh, preceding an election.
So I did an article on Kayfabe,
which is the system of lies that under undergirds wrestling.
And I did one on bitcoin called go virtual young man.
So nobody ever paid attention to my series of answers to the edge question.
So this is the last question.
The last question unprecedented happened when we finally learn our own source
code. Nobody cared. This is the question that obsesses me.
This is what I say I've left this planet is this is what I'm focused on.
What happens if we actually figure out where we are, where this place is?
What are we doing? Who are we,
what built this and who acts on that information. Once we do figure it out,
what steps are taken?
I don't know whether or not the consequences of those steps are ever really
full. You know, I always thought out,
I always tried to talk to somebody like government or the intelligence services.
Like I don't know whether I have something. Maybe I do. Maybe I don't,
but wouldn't, wouldn't,
wouldn't you guys want to know it has a schedule and you know,
never was able to get anybody interested. I, I went through graduate school on
the Office of Naval Researches,
a top grant for graduate study and I always thought they would check in with me,
but they never have.
So like the federal government paid for my postdoc and the military paid for my
graduate education and Harvard doesn't care and they don't, nobody cares.
Nobody believes that anything is possible. Which is the really interesting part.
What do you mean by that? Nobody believes anything in that pot. I mean,
really astronomical breakthroughs. Yeah. Like we all know,
we're waiting to see what, uh, Tim Cook is going to do for the next iPhone.
Will Ilan get to Mars? Does anyone actually care about Mars? I, I'm,
I was there for the Moon landings and let me tell you,
we were bored of the moon by the time we left. It's a very weird thing to say,
but that's something I, I was born in 1965 we were bored. Well,
my perception of the whole Mars thing is it's the shittiest location that we can
get to.
It's a bad name for the best note location that we can get to that isn't this
one? Well, yeah, but it's also like we have spots on earth. Itzhak yeah,
we don't even go there. We don't even go there. But like at least you know,
hats off to Ilan that he at least inspires people by he,
he followed up the scent when we gave up on progress. Right.
So my point is we're not, nobody thinks this is going to work.
I can say it on the show. It can generate a little bit of flurry of activity.
It'll die down within a week. We're going to go back to,
you know who got milkshake, right.
And we're going to want to know is Tulsa is Tulsi gaining on Andrew? You know,
what about Biden can the center hold? Well the fringe come in.
We're just constantly distracted and at least this is going to be entertaining.
We are at three hours and three hours,
three and a half hours. See last time we almost got to four hours.
I'm happy to end it. If people will go to the portal,
the portal with Eric Weinstein on, on apple, apple,
Spotify, Spotify and popular clients for podcast.
I'm sure they will. This is going to be an interesting one. I'm,
I'm really curious to see what kind of blowback this one's going to. Well,
two things, Joe. One, um,
you along with Sam, uh, and my brother,
uh, really encouraged me to do this,
so I'm holding you personally responsible for whatever goes wrong. Um,
the second thing is I really just,
I have such a positive feeling about what you've done, uh,
in terms of empowering people like really touched me that when my brother was
shit out of luck, you did a bunch of shows with him, uh,
and helped him get to a safe place.
And I just want to say that there is like an aspect we we keep talking about.
Is there any use for men whatsoever and standing up in a situation in which you
can take a fair amount of guff, you can take a lot of heat. Uh, you know,
you said this thing to me that was really amazing,
which is that this is a golden age of comedy.
And my interpretation was that there was a period of time where nobody could
figure out how to tell a joke on a college campus.
And our best comedians have figured out how to be compassionate enough and kind
enough and touch the things that are animating us and making us uncomfortable
and that that's what you're a part of. And so I,
I view you as like a very delicate neurosurgeon.
I watched the evolution for example,
of your jokes about professional wrestling being gay right now.
Seriously stay with me Joe. I watched that.
It was always funny, but it got better and better and better.
And the idea that that could be told in a way that you'd be totally comfortable
with, you know,
your gay friend or lover right next to you laughing your ass off.
Taught me a lot about the power of just radiating decency, um,
that well together with analytic thought.
And it's a bit of template. I don't know that I have the skill to pull this off,
but you've been an inspiration.
I just want to say thank you for having me back on the program. My pleasure,
my friend. It's always a pleasure. Thank you. All right. Thank you.
Bye everybody.
That was fucked up.
Okay.
[inaudible].